I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello, everyone. Hi there.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金西。我们曾一起出演《办公室》，而且我们是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并提供只有当时身临其境的两个人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。我们是办公室女郎。大家好。你们好。
Guys, thank you so much for your support of our podcast and watching with us and listening with us. It means so much. And we are loving all of your comments, too. It has been so fun. I have loved going through the comments and going through the questions and the mailbox. By the way, if you want to send us a question, you can send it to officeladiesatearwolf.com. All right.
伙计们，非常感谢你们对我们的播客的支持，感谢你们和我们一起观看、一起收听。这意义重大。我们也喜欢你们所有的评论。这太有趣了。我喜欢浏览评论、问题和信箱。顺便说一句，如果你想给我们发问题，你可以发到 officeladiesatearwolf.com。好了。
Today, we are moving into Season 2, Season 2, Episode 1, The Dundies, written by Mindy Kaling, directed by Greg Daniels. Yes. And you guys out there listening, we really wanted to do a live podcast of this at Achilles. But as it turns out, a lot of stuff is involved in doing that. And we just didn't get it together in time. But we do plan on doing some live podcasts. Yes.
今天，我们要进入第二季，第二季第一集《邓迪奖》（The Dundies），由敏迪·卡灵编剧，格雷格·丹尼尔斯导演。是的。你们这些正在收听的听众，我们真的很想在奇利斯（Chili's）做一期现场播客。但事实证明，这涉及很多事情。我们只是没有及时凑齐。不过我们确实计划做一些现场播客。是的。
And maybe we'll go to Achilles. We have to make that happen. We have to make it happen. For sure. You're allowed back in now. I am. They lifted the ban officially. They did.
也许我们会去奇利斯。我们得让它发生。我们必须让它发生。肯定的。你现在被允许进去了。我是。他们正式解除了禁令。他们确实解除了。
It was like a year and a half ago, so I can now go to Achilles. So we have to make that happen. There is so much to talk about with this episode. I have so many notes, and I'm looking at my notes, and I realize the one thing I don't have is a summary written down. What is wrong with you? Can you believe? I was so excited to get into the episode that I failed to write a summary.
大约是一年半前，所以我现在可以去奇利斯了。所以我们必须让它发生。关于这一集有太多要谈的了。我做了好多笔记，当我看着笔记时，我意识到我唯一没有写下的就是剧情梗概。你怎么回事？你敢信？我太兴奋想要开始聊这一集了，以至于忘了写剧情梗概。
So here we go. I'm going to wing it. In this episode, Manager Michael Scott gives out awards to his employees called The Dundies during a very awkward show at Achilles. How'd I do? You did pretty great. He thinks he's like, you know, an amazing stand-up comedian, performer. I did see that a Dundee, I saw a description online of what a Dundee is.
所以，我们开始吧。我要即兴发挥了。在这一集中，经理迈克尔·斯科特在奇利斯的一场非常尴尬的颁奖活动中，给他的员工们颁发了被称为“邓迪奖”的奖项。我表现得怎么样？你表现得挺棒的。他觉得自己像个，你知道的，了不起的单口喜剧演员、表演者。我确实看到邓迪奖的一个描述，我在网上看到关于什么是邓迪奖的描述。
So if you look up Dundee, it says, a Dundee is an award bestowed annually by Dunder Mifflin Scranton, Regional Manager Michael Scott. In order to maintain morale, everybody gets a Dundee. Where did you read that? Well, I did it. There's a thing called Dunderpedia. Oh! Well, let's start with this fast fact.
如果你查一下邓迪奖，上面说，邓迪奖是邓德米夫林斯克兰分公司区域经理迈克尔·斯科特每年颁发的奖项。为了维持士气，每个人都会得到一个邓迪奖。你在哪儿看到的？好吧，我查了。有个叫邓德百科（Dunderpedia）的东西。哦！好吧，让我们从这个快速事实开始。
It's also a fan question. Aaron asked, where did the idea for The Dundies come from? I don't know. The Dundies were based on an awards presentation that Greg Daniels did for his real-life employees on King of the Hill. Oh my gosh. He was the Michael Scott of King of the Hill. Correct!
这也是一个粉丝的问题。亚伦问，邓迪奖的点子是从哪里来的？我不知道。邓迪奖是根据格雷格·丹尼尔斯为他在现实生活中的《山丘之王》（King of the Hill）员工所做的颁奖典礼改编的。哦天哪。他就是《山丘之王》里的迈克尔·斯科特。没错！
He gave them out in a ceremony and they were called the Swampies. Oh my lord. And he gave out the same businessman statues that Michael gives out. He went into a trophy shop and he saw those statues and it inspired him to do an award show for his employees and then now it graduated into an idea for the office. I actually can really see Greg doing that. I can see him going and buying them and thinking like it would like boost everyone's spirit. Yes, it was a morale booster.
他在一个仪式上把它们颁发出去，它们被称为“沼泽奖”（Swampies）。哦天哪。而且他颁发的是迈克尔颁发的同款商人雕像。他走进一家奖杯店，看到了那些雕像，这启发他为他的员工举办一场颁奖典礼，然后现在它升级成了《办公室》的一个点子。我其实真的能想象格雷格做出那种事。我能想象他去买下它们，并认为这能振奋每个人的精神。是的，这是一个士气振奋剂。
Oh, Greg. This leads me into fast fact number two. The Dundies was the story that Greg wanted to use as the season one episode one pilot. Instead of? Instead of the pilot. Yes. This was his idea for how to kick off the American version of the office, but the network said they preferred we do an adaptation of the British pilot.
哦，格雷格。这让我想到了第二个快速事实。邓迪奖原本是格雷格想用作第一季第一集试播集的故事情节。而不是？而不是试播集。是的。这是他关于如何开启美国版《办公室》的点子，但电视网表示，他们更喜欢我们翻拍英国版的试播集。
Wow. And Greg was very, very disappointed. But if you notice, and Angela, maybe you did notice, there has been a Dundie on Michael's desk from the very beginning. And in our opening credits, and Michael Scott all through season one had a Dundie. It's in the opening credits, but is it on his desk in the episode? Oh, well, no, that I don't know. See, because I don't think it's on his actual desk, but I think it's in the credits.
哇。格雷格感到非常非常失望。但是如果你注意到的话，安吉拉，也许你注意到了，从一开始迈克尔的桌子上就放着一个邓迪奖。在我们的片头字幕里，而且迈克尔·斯科特在整个第一季里都有一个邓迪奖。它在片头字幕里，但它在那一集的桌子上吗？哦，这个我就不知道了。你看，因为我不认为它在他的真办公桌上，但我认为它在片头里。
It's in the credits. Yes. But I do think that even that little bit is that way where Greg had something in his head. Right. He had this idea of these Dundie awards looming for all this time. And finally, when we got picked up, he was able to do something with it. Goodness.
它在片头里。是的。但我确实认为，即使是那一点点，也是格雷格心里有某种想法的表现。没错。他一直把这种邓迪奖悬念的念头藏在脑海里。最后，当我们获得续订时，他就能用它来做点什么了。天哪。
We got a second season. That would really have been a bummer. Or else that little shot in the opening credits would have remained a mystery. What is the little man on his desk? What's the little man with the briefcase? What is it? Are we ready for fast fact number three? We're moving more quickly than I thought we would.
我们获得了第二季。那真的很令人扫兴。否则片头字幕里的那个小镜头就会一直是个谜了。他桌上的那个小人是什么？拿公文包的小人是什么？那是什么？我们准备好迎接第三个快速事实了吗？我们的进度比我想象的要快。
Well, let me just tell you, I'm just letting you go, lady. All right. Jenna, I wish you guys could see her. She came in what looks like a mechanics outfit. Yeah. You're like... It's my green jumpsuit. Her green jumpsuit.
好吧，我只能告诉你，我只是顺着你来，女士。好吧。珍娜，我真希望你们能看到她。她穿得看起来像是一套机修工的衣服。对。你就像……这是我的绿色连体裤。她的绿色连体裤。
But I also have a hat on. A hat on. It's like she came to play. Either that or pilot an airplane. But you are ready. Is there anything assembled? Because I think I look like I could assemble something. Maybe.
但我还戴着一顶帽子。戴着一顶帽子。就好像她是来大干一场的。要么就是去开飞机。但你已经准备好了。有什么东西组装好了吗？因为我觉得我看起来像能组装点什么。也许吧。
Okay, go, go, go. All right. Fast fact number three. The second season of The Office was originally only six episodes long. We only got picked up for six episodes. I know. We were so excited to get six, but after that we're like, well, I guess that's it. That might be all.
好吧，走，走，走。好的。第三个快速事实。《办公室》的第二季原本只有六集。我们只获得了六集的续订。我知道。我们很高兴能拍六集，但那之后我们在想，好吧，我想就这样了。可能就这些了。
But they started airing and then they ordered three more, then they ordered four more. Then I think they ordered the rest of the whole season and we ended up with a usual amount of time. Yeah. And they're like, well, we got six. Well, that's that. Oh, no, we got three more. Oh, we got, you know, it kind of gave you that sense of like, well, we might as well
但它们开始播出，然后他们订购了三集，接着又订购了四集。然后我想他们订购了整季剩下的部分，我们最终得到了通常的时长。是的。他们就想，好吧，我们有六集。好吧，就这样。哦，不，我们又有了三集。哦，我们有了，你知道的，它有点给你那种感觉，好吧，我们不妨放手一搏，因为我们不知道我们能不能保住这份工作。
go for it because we don't know if we're going to win this job. And this episode of The Dundies was actually the third episode that we shot when we came back and it was the first episode that we ever shot away from our office set. Yes. This is the first time we went on a completely different location. It was really, really cool. And we shot this the week after Steve Carell's movie, The 40 Year Old Virgin, hit theaters. Yes.
而《邓迪奖》这一集实际上是我们回来后拍摄的第三集，也是我们第一次在办公室布景之外拍摄的一集。是的。这是我们第一次去完全不同的外景地。真的很酷。我们拍摄这一周正好赶上史蒂夫·卡瑞尔的电影《四十岁的老处男》上映。是的。
It was the number one movie at the box office. We were so excited for him. And Steve being the sweetheart that he has invited the whole entire cast to the premiere. Yeah. And we all went and we got dressed up. And that was like one of the first fancy movie anything parties I've ever been to. I have a crazy story about that, Angela. What?
它是票房排名第一的电影。我们为他感到非常高兴。而史蒂夫作为那个大好人，邀请了整个剧组去参加首映式。是的。我们都去了，还盛装打扮。那是我去过的第一个高档电影派对。关于那件事我有一个疯狂的故事，安吉拉。什么？
Well, we had been shooting all day and then the premiere was that night. Yeah. We got dressed on set and the hair and makeup people did our hair and makeup and we carpooled and we went to this premiere. And when we got there, I was wearing this dress. It's very hard to explain. Maybe we can find a photo of it and put it on our website. It was sort of like a lacy mermaid thing.
好吧，我们拍了一整天，然后首映礼就在那天晚上。是的。我们在片场换好衣服，发型和化妆师给我们弄好头发和妆容，我们拼车去了首映礼。当我们到达那里时，我穿着这条裙子。这很难解释。也许我们可以找到一张照片把它放到我们的网站上。它有点像那种蕾丝美人鱼裙。
It was like green and blue. What? I don't even remember where I got it or how I got it. It was my first big movie premiere. Right. I didn't know what you were supposed to wear or how you were supposed to dress. It was a silky dress and then over it was a lace part. So the silk part was like the slip and then the lace part went over.
它是绿蓝色的。什么？我甚至不记得我是从哪里买的，怎么买的。这是我的第一场大型电影首映礼。没错。我不知道你该穿什么，也不知道该怎么打扮。那是一条丝绸裙子，外面有一层蕾丝。所以丝绸部分就像是衬裙，然后蕾丝部分罩在外面。
Yes. A silk slip. Thank you, Angela. And it was blue and green sort of mermaidy colors, I guess. And it had this really big ribbon around the hips. What is happening with this dress? I'll tell you. And then it had the ribbon tassels were hanging down in the front.
是的。丝绸衬裙。谢谢你，安吉拉。它有蓝色和绿色，有点像美人鱼的颜色，我猜。它的臀部周围系着一条非常大的缎带。这条裙子到底是怎么回事？我来告诉你。然后缎带的流苏垂在前面。
In the front. Okay. So when we got to the premiere, I had to pee so badly. So before we walked the red carpet, I ran into the bathroom and I peed very quickly. Did you pee on the ribbon? I did not pee on the ribbon. Okay. No, that would have been awful.
在前面。好吧。所以当我们到达首映礼时，我尿急得不行。所以在我们走红毯之前，我跑进洗手间，飞快地尿了。你尿在缎带上了吗？我没有尿在缎带上。好的。不，那可就太糟糕了。
That's where I thought the story was going. No, the ribbon did not dip in the toilet. Okay. But you know, that happens sometimes. Yeah, I said that because I feel like it's happened to me. Okay. I did not pee on the ribbon, but I was rushing. And I came back out and I went to the red carpet.
我还以为故事是朝那个方向发展呢。没有，缎带没有泡在马桶里。好的。但你知道，有时会发生这种事。是的，我这么说是觉得这种事好像发生在我身上过。好的。我没有尿在缎带上，但我当时很匆忙。我出来后就上了红毯。
I took my pictures, I posed, I did the pictures, whirlwind, hoped I did it right, went inside. When I got inside, I realized that I had tucked the slip into my underwear. No. Was your butt showing in the lace in the photos? No, my butt was not showing. Thankfully, that ribbon was strategically poised to cover my lady bits. Oh, Jenna, oh my God. Because it was just lace on the bottom because I had tucked the slip into my underwear, but
我拍了照片，摆了姿势，拍了照，像旋风一样，希望我没做错，然后进去了。当我进去后，我意识到我把衬裙塞进内裤里了。不会吧。照片里你的屁股在蕾丝里露出来了吗？没有，我的屁股没有露出来。谢天谢地，那条缎带战略性地挡住了我的女性私密部位。哦，珍娜，我的天哪。因为下面只有蕾丝，因为我把衬裙塞进内裤里了，但是
it gets worse. What? How can it get worse than you tucked your, also, didn't you feel some air in places you should have been filling air? I was so nervous. You were rushing. I was rushing. You were rushing.
情况更糟糕。什么？怎么会比你把，而且，难道你在一些本该撑起空间的地方感觉不到有风吗？我当时太紧张了。你很匆忙。我很匆忙。你很匆忙。
Okay, okay, okay. I wanted to get into my friend Steve's big movie premiere. Okay. How does it get worse? When you go and you buy, like, the three-pack of cotton underwear at Target, and there's a white pair, a black pair, a new pair, and then a crazy color pair, I was wearing the crazy pair from my Target underwear pack, and I think, like, from the back, you must have been able to see it.
好吧，好吧，好吧。我想去参加我朋友史蒂夫的大电影首映礼。好吧。怎么会更糟糕？当你去塔吉特（Target）买那种三包装的纯棉内裤时，里面有一条白色的、一条黑色的、一条新的，然后还有一条花哨颜色的，我穿着从塔吉特内裤套装里拿出来的那条花哨颜色的，我想，从后面看，你一定能看到它。
Thankfully, I didn't turn around on the red carpet, but I'm sure many people saw that as I was walking. Jenna, I do not remember if I did the red carpet or not. I don't know if I did. I think I just went in the theater. I mean, I would have to go back and look, but I feel like I didn't even know that we had to do that. And I kind of-
谢天谢地，我在红毯上没有转身，但我确信当我走路时很多人都看到了。珍娜，我不记得我有没有走红毯了。我不知道我有没有走。我想我只是走进了剧院。我的意思是，我得回去看看，但我感觉我甚至不知道我们必须这样做。而且我有点——
Someone made me do it. Like, I got out of the car and, you know, someone grabbed me and said, you need to take pictures. I was- I'm pretty sure I drove myself and I just parked in the garage and I walked in. But I just remember being so excited for Steve, and he was so happy we were there. He had us all sitting together and he came over and he gave us all a big hug. And I kind of remember that he wore a white suit.
有人逼我这么做的。就像，我下了车，你知道的，有人抓住了我说，你需要拍照。我——我很确定我是自己开的车，我只是把车停在车库里，然后走了进去。但我只记得为史蒂夫感到非常高兴，他很高兴我们在那儿。他让我们所有人坐在一起，他走过来给我们一个大大的拥抱。我隐约记得他穿了一套白色西装。
Am I remembering that right? Don't know. Don't know. Should have looked it up. We were doing the dundies today. I don't think I bought anything new. I don't remember what I wore. I sat between John and Rain at the premiere when the movie was over.
我没记错吧？不知道。不知道。真该查一下。我们今天拍的是邓迪奖。我猜我没买什么新衣服。我不记得我穿了什么。电影结束时，我和约翰还有雷恩坐在首映礼上。
I turned to John and I said, Steve is going to be the biggest movie star when this movie comes out. Yeah. He's going to stop being Steve. He's going to start being Steve Carell. Yeah. And it's going to be weird because we know Steve, and the rest of the world is going to know Steve Carell in about one week.
我转向约翰说，等这部电影上映时，史蒂夫会成为最大的电影明星。是的。他将不再只是史蒂夫。他将开始成为史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。是的。这会很奇怪，因为我们认识史蒂夫，而世界其他地方将在大约一周后认识史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。
I remember thinking like, holy moly, this is going to be a big hit. So now we're shooting the dundies. Yes. The 40-year-old virgin has come out and as predicted, Steve is Steve Carell. He's a huge movie star. And since we're on location, they had to economize space. And we were each given these teeny, teeny, tiny trailers. To change clothes then, basically.
我记得当时想，天哪，这会是一个巨大的热门。所以现在我们在拍邓迪奖。是的。《四十岁的老处男》上映了，正如预测的那样，史蒂夫就是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。他是个超级巨星。由于我们在外景地，他们不得不节约空间。我们每个人都分到了这些极其极其微小的拖车。基本上就是用来换衣服的。
That's right. That's all you could do. That's all you could do. It's about the size of a closet. Even Steve, biggest movie star in the country, did not get a larger closet to change in. And his was infested with ants. And I will just never forget how humble he was and how he did not complain at all. And I thought, you know what?
没错。你只能做这个。你只能做这个。它大约只有一个衣橱那么大。就连史蒂夫，这个全国最大的电影明星，也没有得到一个更大的衣橱来换衣服。而且他的里面爬满了蚂蚁。我永远不会忘记他是多么谦逊，他一点也没有抱怨。我想，你知道吗？
That is how you behave with class. Yes. And Steve is not a complainer and he's professional and he's on time and he gets his shiitake done. And he even joked about it. He was like, well, that's how they keep you humble in this business. It was great. It was so great.
这才是风度翩翩的行为。是的，史蒂夫从不抱怨，他很专业，他很准时，他能把事情办妥。他甚至还拿这开玩笑。他说，好吧，这就是在这个行业里保持谦逊的方式。这太棒了。太棒了。
I have a fourth fast fact, Angela. But Jenna, you only do three fast facts. But this is the dundies. The dundies deserves a fourth fast fact. Okay. So fast fact number four. And this was based on a lot of questions from fans about the Chili's location. It was not a real Chili's.
安吉拉，我还有第四个快速事实。但是珍娜，你通常只说三个快速事实。但这是邓迪奖。邓迪奖值得拥有第四个快速事实。好吧。所以是第四个快速事实。这基于粉丝们关于奇利斯餐厅地点的很多问题。它不是真正的奇利斯。
In fact, it was an out-of-business restaurant. We got permission from Chili's to make it a Chili's. And they sent all their gear, all their signs and their chalkboard stuff to make it look like a Chili's. Yes. They spent weeks, Michael Gallenberg, our set designer, spent weeks conferring with Chili's, reconstructing with painstaking detail this Chili's restaurant, which was in an abandoned former restaurant.
事实上，它是一家倒闭的餐厅。我们得到了奇利斯公司的许可，把它布置成一家奇利斯餐厅。他们寄来了所有的装备、所有的招牌和黑板上的东西，让它看起来像一家奇利斯。是的。他们花了几个星期，我们的布景设计师迈克尔·加伦伯格（Michael Gallenberg）花了几周时间与奇利斯协商，以煞费苦心的细节重建了这家奇利斯餐厅，它坐落在一个废弃的前餐厅里。
It was in an abandoned restaurant and an empty parking lot. And it, I mean, it didn't even have any signs or anything on it when they started. It was just an out-of-business restaurant. Yeah. So there you go, guys. You can't, and what's crazy about that is you can't go eat at that Chili's. It is near a mall and on my lunch break, I wanted a mask and snorkel and I went, yeah, so this is a story that's not that interesting.
它坐落在一个废弃的餐厅和一个空停车场里。而且，我的意思是，他们开始时上面甚至没有任何标志或其他东西。它只是一家倒闭的餐厅。是的。所以，伙计们，你们不能，最疯狂的是，你不能去那家奇利斯吃饭。它在一个购物中心附近，在我的午休时间，我想要一个潜水面罩和呼吸管，然后我去了，是的，所以这是一个不太有趣的故事。
But when we filmed, listen, we filmed at this random neighborhood, this out-of-business restaurant. And I just happened to see that it was near like a mall and I was able on my lunch break to get a snorkel and a mask. For what reason? I wanted to go snorkeling. I was going to go, but this is what I remember about this restaurant is like, oh, that's the restaurant.
但当我们拍摄时，听着，我们在一个随机的街区拍摄，这家倒闭的餐厅。我碰巧看到它靠近一个购物中心，我在午休时间买到了呼吸管和面罩。出于什么原因？我想去浮潜。我打算去，但关于这家餐厅我记住的是，哦，那是那家餐厅。
Snorkeling where? It's like at the ocean, Jenna. I was going to go to Catalina Island, listen, the details aren't important. What is important is when I think about that out-of-business restaurant that we filmed in as a Chili's is that that's near where I bought my mask and snorkel. Do you still have your mask and snorkel? It broke. Here's the thing, guys, if you want to not eat at that Chili's and also buy a broken
去哪儿浮潜？就像在大海里，珍娜。我本来打算去卡特琳娜岛，听着，细节并不重要。重要的是，当我想到我们在其中拍摄并当作奇利斯的那家倒闭的餐厅时，那就在我买面罩和呼吸管的地方附近。你还留着你的面罩和呼吸管吗？它坏了。事情是这样的，伙计们，如果你不想去那家奇利斯吃饭，同时还想买一个坏掉的面罩和呼吸管。
mask and snorkel. Get a crappy mask and snorkel. You can head out to wherever that was. I think it was in Panorama City. Deep in the valley of Los Angeles. Do you want to take a break? Yeah, let's do a break. And then we'll get into this episode.
买个破烂的面罩和呼吸管。你可以去任何那个地方。我想是在全景城（Panorama City）。洛杉矶山谷深处。你想休息一下吗？好吧，我们休息一下吧。然后我们再进入这一集。
Okay. So much to say. We have so much to say and I have all my note cards. Some of them are really great. Some of them, I don't know, guys. Some of them are just a mask and snorkel. Did you see? Oh, well, listen.
好的。有太多要说的了。我们有太多要说的，我所有的记事卡都在这。有些真的很棒。有些，我不知道，伙计们。有些只是一个面罩和呼吸管。你看到了吗？哦，好吧，听着。
That means dud. Oh, okay. Well, do you want to talk more about the ants in the trailer? The ants in the trailer were interesting. You want to tell another riveting insect story? We'll be right back. So, you guys, we were going to a break and while we went to a break, I Googled Jenna's dress at the four-year-old virgin and I see what you mean.
那意味着是个废品。哦，好吧，你想多聊聊拖车里的蚂蚁吗？拖车里的蚂蚁很有趣。你想讲另一个引人入胜的昆虫故事吗？我们马上回来。所以，伙计们，我们要去休息一下，在我们休息的时候，我用谷歌搜索了珍娜在《四十岁的老处男》首映礼上的裙子，我明白你的意思了。
You see how it's kind of mermaid-y? It is kind of mermaid-y. You see why I described it that way? It also looks like this is like someone told you when you pose, stick your arms on your hips and stick your chest out a little. Yeah, totally digital. Look at that. Boom.
你看它是不是有点像美人鱼？确实有点像美人鱼。你知道我为什么那样描述它了吧？看起来也像是有人告诉你摆姿势时，把手叉在腰上，把胸挺起来一点。是的，完全是数字化的。看看那个。砰。
Well, I want to say that in addition to attending the premiere, Angela, do you remember that you and I went and saw it a second time together, just the two of us as BFFs and we took a picture with Steve's poster in the lobby? We went on our own because we were just so excited for Steve. I still have it. I have a photo of you and I standing next to his face on a poster in the movie theater. I'm sure people were like, what are those two up to? Did we get into this episode as Angela continues to scroll through pictures of me at this premiere
嗯，我想说，除了出席首映礼，安吉拉，你还记得你和我一起第二次去看了它，只有我们两个好朋友，我们在大厅里和史蒂夫的海报合影了吗？我们自己去的，因为我们太为史蒂夫高兴了。我还留着。我有一张你和我站在电影院海报上他的脸旁边的照片。我敢肯定人们会想，这两个人在搞什么鬼？当我们进入这一集时，安吉拉继续滚动浏览我在这次首映礼上的照片，寻找我那条疯狂的塔吉特内裤？
looking for my crazy target underwear? I'm sure. Oh, Steve did wear a white suit. He wore a white suit. I remembered that correctly. There are no photos for me. All right, let's get into this episode in the very opening shot of Pam at her desk. I don't know if you notice this, Angela, as our background expert, but I am holding my
我确信。哦，史蒂夫确实穿了一套白色西装。他穿了一套白色西装。我没记错。我没有照片。好吧，让我们进入这一集，在帕姆坐在办公桌前的第一个开场镜头中。安吉拉，作为我们的背景专家，我不知道你有没有注意到这一点，我手里拿着我的工作鞋。
work shoes in my hand. I've just arrived at work and I'm holding my work shoes and this was something that we did but did not mention. It was to establish that she wears her white Keds to work and then changes into her work shoes. Which a lot of people do. A lot of people do. A lot of people who live in New York City and walk or use the subway.
我刚到公司，手里拿着工作鞋，这是我们做过但没有提及的事情。这是为了确定她穿着白色的Keds鞋上班，然后换上她的工作鞋。很多人都这样。很多人都这样做。很多住在纽约市、步行或坐地铁的人。
I'm not sure why Pam, who is driven to work by her fiance, needs to work Keds in the car. So it is. Well, maybe Pam only has the one pair of shoes that are her nice shoes and she doesn't want to muck them up. Well, this is how she keeps her Keds so white is because she just wears them in a car in case you were wondering. All right, so moving on to Michael's talking head describing the dundies. Everyone wrote in about this.
我不确定为什么由未婚夫开车送去上班的帕姆需要在车里穿Keds鞋。事实就是这样。好吧，也许帕姆只有一双漂亮的鞋子，她不想弄脏它们。好吧，这就是为什么她的Keds鞋能保持这么白，因为她只在车里穿，以防你想知道。好吧，那么接下来是迈克尔关于邓迪奖的访谈。每个人都写信来问这个。
Why does Steve look so different in the first shot of him in this episode? Well, I know why because the summer that he was going to film, 40-year-old Virgin, he got in crazy amazing shape. Amazing shape. And then he's maintained that. He's just like, he's very fit now. He sort of like made that part of his life. They just gave him a whole new look too.
为什么史蒂夫在这集的第一个镜头里看起来如此不同？嗯，我知道为什么，因为他要拍摄《四十岁的老处男》的那年夏天，他的身材练得好得惊人。惊人的身材。然后他保持了那个状态。他只是，他现在非常健康。他有点把这融入了他的生活。他们也给他换了一个全新的造型。
They juged him up. Well, originally his character was based on the British show and the boss there. So they really mirrored his look after David Brent. And when Steve came back so much thinner and just looking amazing, they used it as an excuse. Yeah, I mean, he just looked healthy. He looked healthy. He was great. And the first season, I know they put this gel in his hair.
他们把他打扮了一番。好吧，最初他的角色是基于英国版和那里的老板。所以他们的造型真的模仿了大卫·布伦特（David Brent）。而当史蒂夫回来时变得更瘦、看起来棒极了时，他们就以此为借口。是的，我的意思是，他看起来很健康。他看起来很健康。他太棒了。在第一季，我知道他们在他的头发里抹了这种发胶。
They like slicked it back to look like David Brent. And then after that, they were like, okay, let's style his hair different. And then Jen and I actually, you guys, we were talking about this because this would crack us up. The guys had all their own hair accessories and hair and makeup trailer. And one of them was like the tiniest little rolling brush that they would get their hair blown out like a little bouffant. But it was really tiny.
他们把它向后梳，看起来像大卫·布伦特。然后在那之后，他们想，好吧，让我们换个发型。然后珍娜和我实际上，你们知道的，我们在谈论这个，因为这会让我们大笑。男士们在发型和化妆拖车里都有自己的美发用品。其中之一就是最小的卷发刷，他们会把头发吹成像个小蓬蓬头。但它真的很小。
And Brian and Rain had, remember that teeny, tiny little flat iron. It's the tiniest flat iron. It could fit in your pocket. It was like a joke. It looked like an envelope opener. Yes. But it was a flat iron. It was so small.
而且布莱恩和雷恩有，还记得那个微小的扁平夹板吗。那是最小的夹板。它能放进口袋里。就像个笑话。它看起来像个拆信刀。是的。但它是个夹板。它太小了。
And they would flat iron their tiny bands. Why did the men all have these like miniature, except like almost something you would use on a doll? That's what it looked like. It was so weird. But yeah. So it totally changed the way Steve looked. And Steve himself had just gotten an amazing shape.
他们会用它夹平他们小小的刘海。为什么男士们都有这种微型的，除了几乎像是你会用在洋娃娃身上的东西？看起来就是这样。太奇怪了。但是，是的。所以它完全改变了史蒂夫的外表。史蒂夫自己也刚刚练就了惊人的身材。
Well, we also a little bit adjusted the character of Michael Scott as well. Finally, I think they felt like when they got the pickup for season two, they could really make this for Steve. They could really base it more on what Steve was going to bring to the character. And for example, in this episode later, we'll talk about it. Michael gets hazed and you see him really wounded. And that was a choice. That was a choice to make Michael a little bit more, I don't know, sympathetic.
好吧，我们也对迈克尔·斯科特这个角色做了一点调整。最后，我想他们觉得当他们获得第二季的续订时，他们可以真正为史蒂夫打造这个角色。他们可以真正更多地根据史蒂夫将为这个角色带来的特质来塑造他。例如，在本集后面的内容中，我们会谈到这一点。迈克尔被捉弄了，你看到他真的很受伤。这是一个选择。这是一个选择，让迈克尔变得稍微，我不知道，更有同情心一点。
Well, I feel like in season two, they started doing a thing with Michael's character. And I'm sure you guys watching noticed this as well, is that as awkward and cringy as he could be and really not aware of the things he said and how they affected people, they would give him one moment that was redeeming, one moment in the episode where you rooted for him or felt bad for him so that it wasn't just all like, oh, that guy is such a jerk. Instead of the onslaught of insults that season one had been. Right. They just made him have one moment where you were just sympathetic towards him.
嗯，我觉得在第二季中，他们开始对迈克尔的角色做一件事。我确信观看的你们也注意到了这一点，那就是尽管他可能会很尴尬、很让人起鸡皮疙瘩，而且真的没有意识到他说的话以及它们如何影响别人，但他们会给他一个救赎的时刻，在这一集里有一个时刻让你为他加油或为他感到难过，这样它就不会全都是，“哦，这家伙真是个混蛋。”而不是第一季那种猛烈的侮辱。没错。他们只是让他有一个时刻，让你对产生同情。
So I hope that solves the mystery for all of you about why did Steve suddenly look different? So next we have Pam's talking head about the dundies. She's sitting in the conference room and Pam has so much residual anger. Do you see how like deeply angry she is about the dundies? And also though the dundies just keep poking that wound about her engagement. Yes. Oh, yeah. And then we move on to the scene where Pam, Meredith, and Kelly are laughing about how
所以我希望这能为你们所有关于“为什么史蒂夫突然看起来不同”的疑问解开谜团。接下来是帕姆关于邓迪奖的访谈。她坐在会议室里，帕姆积聚了太多的愤怒。你看她对邓迪奖有多么深恶痛绝吗？而且邓迪奖也不断戳中她订婚的那块伤疤。是的。哦，是的。然后我们进入接下来的场景，帕姆、梅雷迪思和凯利在嘲笑洗手间墙上有人写了关于迈克尔的坏话。
someone wrote something on the bathroom wall in the ladies room about Michael. Yes. And this is funny. Mindy said people always talk about how the dundies is about an award show, but she thinks it's also a mystery about who wrote on the bathroom wall. You guys were like, oh, it's just something funny. And then Dwight's like, what was it, Dave Berry? He is like a humorist.
这很有趣。敏迪说人们总是谈论邓迪奖是一个颁奖典礼，但她认为这也是一个关于谁在卫生间墙上留言的谜团。你们当时就像，哦，这只是件有趣的事。然后德怀特说，是谁，戴夫·巴里（Dave Berry）？他是个幽默作家。
He had a column in the Miami Herald that became a TV show called Dave's World. Oh, yeah. So that is who Rain would consider. That was his go-to funny. Yeah. Go-to funny person. Did you notice in that scene that Kelly is still not fully transformed? She's getting there though.
他在《迈阿密先驱报》有一个专栏，后来变成了一个名为《戴夫的世界》（Dave's World）的电视节目。哦，是的。所以这就是雷恩会想到的人。那是他的首选幽默人物。是的。首选的搞笑人物。你注意到那一幕里凯利还没有完全转变吗？不过她快了。
Her hair is now half up, half down. Yes. Yes, she's getting there and she had some brighter lipstick on. But she still has that high neck paisley blouse. And also did you notice that Mindy is basically laughing through the entire scene? Yes. But you know what? When I watched it, I was like, how happy was Mindy that she was allowed to laugh because
她的头发现在是一半扎起一半放下。是的。是的，她快成功了，而且她涂了更亮丽的口红。但她仍然穿着那件高领腰果花衬衫。而且你注意到敏迪基本上在整场戏中都在笑吗？是的。但你知道吗？当我观看时，我在想，敏迪能笑是有多开心，因为
she was going to be laughing anyway? Yes. Mindy laughed through all of her acting takes. A lot of them. Always. Yeah. So I thought she must have been just so tickled that she got to be laughing. So the next scene is Michael's on his phone call with Jan where he throws the camera out
她反正也会笑的？是的。敏迪在她所有的演戏镜头里都在笑。很多都是。总是这样。是的。所以我想她一定很高兴自己能笑个不停。所以接下来的场景是迈克尔在和简打电话，他把摄像机扔出了办公室。
of his office. I loved that. I did too. I love that he throws the camera out. He's like, get out, get out, get out. And she is giving him trouble because she says we're not going to pay for the dundies this year. She also lists what she considers some of his failed parties, which were the, she was
我喜欢那个。我也喜欢。我喜欢他把摄像机扔出去。他喊着，滚开，滚开，滚开。她在找他的麻烦，因为她说今年我们不会为邓迪奖买单了。她还列举了她认为他失败的一些派对，也就是，她当时说，
like, you just threw a party on May 5th and he goes, it was 05, 05, 05. It happens once every billion years. And then she goes, in a luau, you threw a luau. And then she was like, and you had a tsunami relief fundraiser that lost money. Oh, by the way, by the way, he goes, no, it wasn't a fundraiser. It was a fundraiser. And then Michael has a talking head where he puts the envelope to his head, which is a riff on a bit that Johnny Carson used to do on the Tonight Show.
你刚在5月5日办了一个派对，他说，那是05年05月05日。这十亿年才发生一次。然后她说，还有夏威夷草裙舞会，你办了一个草裙舞会。然后她说，你还有一个亏了钱的海啸救援募捐活动。哦，顺便说一句，顺便说一句，他说，不，这不是募捐活动。这就是募捐活动。然后迈克尔做了一个访谈，他把信封贴在头上，这是在恶搞约翰尼·卡森（Johnny Carson）以前在《今夜秀》（The Tonight Show）上做过的一个桥段。
Greg told us that the joke that Michael does in this scene with the envelope was the first joke that Greg ever wrote. Really? He wrote it as a kid. He wrote it for his dad, who used to do a presentation at work when Greg was younger. He did a riff. His dad did a riff for his own employees. On Johnny Carson.
格雷格告诉我们，迈克尔在本集里用信封开的玩笑是格雷格写出的第一个笑话。真的吗？他小时候写的。他是写给他爸爸的，格雷格小时候他爸爸经常在工作时做演讲。他做了一个即兴恶搞。他爸爸为自己的员工做了一个恶搞。模仿约翰尼·卡森。
Yeah. He wrote it in this episode. That is adorable. Yeah. That is adorable. So then we have the scene where Dwight is sneaking into the woman's restroom. And he goes in, but he doesn't realize Phyllis is still there and she throws him out. Can you see rain breaking?
是的。他在这一集里写了这个。太可爱了。是的。太可爱了。然后我们看到德怀特溜进女洗手间的场景。他进去了，但他没有意识到菲利斯还在里面，她把他赶了出去。你能看到雷恩笑场了吗？
Right, yes. Look at my note card. He is almost breaking. He's almost breaking. I have one Phyllis chases Dwight out of the bathroom. Look at that. Rain is about to laugh. For sure.
对，是的。看我的记事卡。他差一点就笑场了。他快憋不住了。我写着：菲利斯把德怀特赶出洗手间。看那个。雷恩快要笑了。肯定的。
For sure. I love that, though. Phyllis just owned him in that moment. It was so great. So I have a note card because this cracked me up at seven minutes, nine seconds. Dwight gets everyone's attention. He's very mad at the ladies of the office, right? And he makes this announcement.
肯定的。不过我喜欢那个。菲利斯在那一刻简直碾压了他。太棒了。所以我有一张记事卡，因为在七分九秒时这让我大笑出神。德怀特吸引了所有人的注意。他对办公室里的女士们非常生气，对吧？他发表了这个声明。
And when he comes out to make this announcement, the camera shot starts over Stanley's shoulder. And Stanley is playing with a toy car. He is? He is holding a bright blue toy car. It's a convertible. The doors are open on it like he's been opening the doors. And he holds this blue convertible toy car throughout the scene. And you see it a few times.
当他出来发表这个声明时，镜头是从斯坦利的肩膀上方开始的。斯坦利正在玩一个玩具车。他在玩吗？他手里拿着一辆亮蓝色的玩具车。那是一辆敞篷车。上面的车门开着，就像他一直在开门一样。他在整个场景中一直拿着这辆蓝色的敞篷玩具车。你看到了好几次。
And I was like, what? What is that? What is that? I don't know. But it cracked me up. And I remember that he had some cars on his desk. Do you remember that? I don't.
当时我就想，什么？那是什么？那是什么？我不知道。但这让我大笑。我记得他的桌子上有一些车。你记得吗？我不记得。
I don't know why I forgot that Dwight had bobbleheads. But I know that Stanley has, like, cars. Something that never becomes a plot point is sneered in your brain. And not a plot point to my character. Specifically. I know. Well, did you notice, Angela, that in the background of that same scene, if you look at Meredith's computer, you can see she's in the middle of a free-sell game?
我不知道为什么我忘了德怀特有摇头娃娃。但我知道斯坦利有，比如，车。一个从未成为情节核心的细节却深深印在你的脑海里。而且对我的角色来说也不是情节核心。特地说明一下。我知道。好吧，安吉拉，你注意到在同一个场景的背景中，如果你看梅雷迪思的电脑，你可以看到她正在玩空当接龙游戏吗？
Oh, no. I didn't see that. Yes. So in later seasons, after we got internet and we stopped playing free-sell, we would get in trouble if we had unapproved things on our screens. Do you remember that? Oh, yeah. I do.
哦，不。我没看到。是的。所以在后来的几季中，在我们有了互联网并停止玩空当接龙之后，如果我们屏幕上有未经批准的东西，我们就会惹上麻烦。你记得吗？哦，是的。我记得。
The camera guys would say, Angela, we can totally see your email account. I'd be like, ah, OK. I'd like minimize it. Or if you were looking at a website, there were certain things that we were allowed to show on computer screens like fake documents, the Dunder Mifflin logo, free-sell games. I guess we got that cleared. But we couldn't have other stuff, and we would get yelled at. And then Rain said, you never have to tell me again about the screens, all right?
摄影师会说，安吉拉，我们完全能看到你的电子邮箱账号。我会说，啊，好吧。我会把它最小化。或者如果你在看一个网站，有些东西是允许在电脑屏幕上显示的，比如假文件、邓迪夫林标志、空当接龙游戏。我想我们已经获得了批准。但我们不能有其他东西，我们会挨训。然后雷恩说，你再也不用提醒我关于屏幕的事了，好吗？
Stop hounding me about the screens. In fact, if you ever find something on my screen while we're shooting that's not allowed to be there, I will donate $100 to charity every time. Why was he so annoyed? I don't know. Such a being has bought it. He had to pay out so much, because he would forget. Oh, and the camera guys would hold him to it.
别再为屏幕的事纠缠我了。事实上，如果在我们拍摄时你在我的屏幕上发现任何不允许出现的东西，我每次都会向慈善机构捐款100美元。他为什么那么恼火？我不知道。这种人竟然同意了。他不得不支付好多钱，因为他总是忘。哦，摄影师会抓住这一点不放。
Yes, because he made this big declaration, you never need to tell me again. And water bottles. We used to get in trouble for having soda cans or whatever on our desks. I mean, you don't watch Game of Thrones, but there was a Starbucks coffee cup that really... Don't watch Game of Thrones, and yet I did get into the coffee gate situation. I thought, how in the world... How do they miss that? I mean, there's a Starbucks coffee thing next to like a dragon on the ground.
是的，因为他发表了这种宏大的声明，你再也不用提醒我了。还有水瓶。我们以前经常因为桌上有汽罐或其他东西而惹上麻烦。我的意思是，你不看《权力的游戏》，但那里有一个星巴克的咖啡杯真的……不看《权力的游戏》，然而我确实卷入了咖啡门事件。我想，这到底是怎么回事……他们怎么会漏掉那个？我的意思是，地上的一条龙旁边居然有一个星巴克的咖啡杯。
I mean, that's a whole other world. There are not even Starbucks in that world. At least if we left a Starbucks on our desk, you could be like, well, I guess they went to Starbucks. Yeah, I just have to say something that in watching this again made me laugh out loud is that Michael is trying to make everyone feel good about the dundies. He's so wounded that people aren't excited. This clearly means so much to him, and he can't believe that no one else shares his
我的意思是，那是另一个世界。那个世界甚至没有星巴克。至少如果我们在桌上留下一个星巴克，你还可以想，好吧，我想他们去过星巴克了。是的，我必须说一件事，再次观看时让我大笑出声，那就是迈克尔正试图让每个人对邓迪奖感觉良好。看到大家都不兴奋，他真的很受伤。这显然对他意义重大，他不敢相信别人不和他一样对邓迪奖充满热情，也看不到它们有多么重要。
enthusiasm for the dundies and sees how important they are. So as a way to try to get them back into it, he says, listen, friends and family are invited to the dundies for the first time. For the first time? Do you mean all these years that he's been doing the dundies, he's never let them bring plus ones? I couldn't believe that. I was like, what?
所以为了把他们重新吸引进来，他说，听着，朋友和家人第一次被邀请参加邓迪奖了。第一次？你是说这么多年来他一直在办邓迪奖，他从来没让他们带过女伴/男伴吗？我简直不敢相信。当时我就想，什么？
And everyone was like, oh, great. Everyone is like, genuinely happy about it. Yes. I was like, oh my gosh, it was like employees only? Oh my lord. And later, you realize that no one is paid for, that everyone now, their bill is going to be double. Double.
每个人都说，哦，太棒了。每个人都像是，由衷地高兴。是的。当时我就想，哦天哪，这就像是仅限员工吗？哦天哪。然后后来，你意识到没有人买单，每个人现在的账单都会翻倍。翻倍。
Because they brought a plus one. And they wouldn't have probably even brought anyone. So now, guys, we are going to move to the chilies. Oh, here we go. It's time to go to chilies. Here we go. And if we look like we're sweating, it's because it was over 100 degrees when we shot this episode, and there was very little air conditioning inside this abandoned restaurant.
因为他们带了女伴/男伴。而且他们可能根本不会带任何人。所以现在，伙计们，我们要去奇利斯了。哦，来了。是时候去奇利斯了。我们走吧。如果我们看起来在流汗，那是因为我们拍摄这一集时气温超过了100华氏度，而且这家废弃餐厅里面的空调开得很小。
I'm absolutely fine, because when I'm completely comfortable, everyone is miserable. So I was doing OK as well. But the gentlemen, the men wearing suits, were... Well, poor Steve. I mean, tuxedo. And then he would put things on top of the tuxedo. Yeah. Yeah.
我完全没问题，因为当我完全舒适时，每个人都很痛苦。所以我当时也过得挺好。但是绅士们，那些穿着西装的男士们，他们……好吧，可怜的史蒂夫。我的意思是，燕尾服。然后他还要在燕尾服外面穿东西。是的。是的。
We spent three full days filming there. And we also had to sometimes wear coats, because we were pretending like it was fall. Right. If you see rain, he's got that big trench coat on. It always worked out that way. We would film all these episodes that we'll talk about where we were in coats and suits and stuff outside, and it was August. Or we would have to pretend like it was spring, but we were shooting it during the winter
我们在那里拍了整整三天。有时我们还得穿外套，因为我们要假装是秋天。没错。如果你看到雷恩，他穿着那件厚重的大衣。事情总是这样安排的。我们会拍摄所有这些我们稍后会谈到的外景穿着外套和西装的戏份，而当时是八月份。或者我们不得不假装那是春天，但我们在冬天拍摄，我们会冻僵。
and we would be freezing. Yes. We never shot the episodes during the time of year in which they were. I love Oscar's talking head, his description of the dundies, comparing them to a children's party. He did that so well. It was so spot on. Oscar always has some of my favorite talking heads.
是的。我们从来没有在故事发生的那个季节拍摄这些剧集。我喜欢奥斯卡的访谈，他对邓迪奖的描述，把它比作一个儿童派对。他演得太棒了。简直太贴切了。奥斯卡总有一些我最喜欢的访谈。
He's brilliant. He's an amazing actor. He really is. Oscar describes the dundies as a child's birthday party, and Pam compares it to an accident that you're forced to look at. You're forced to look at. I have a question for you, Jenna. Yeah.
他太才华横溢了。他是个了不起的演员。真的。奥斯卡把邓迪奖形容为一个孩子的生日派对，而帕姆把它比作一场你被迫去看的事故。被迫去看的。我有一个问题要问你，珍娜。是的。
All right. I read when I was looking back over the dundies, I read an article that said that BJ Novak took Jenna out to get drunk in real life and then let her know what her responses were like, because you don't really drink that much in real life. So he took you out drinking. Is that true? Yes. What?
好吧。我回看邓迪奖的时候读到一篇文章，上面说BJ·诺瓦克（BJ Novak）在现实生活中带珍娜出去喝醉了，然后让她知道她的反应是什么样子的，因为你在现实生活中其实不怎么喝酒。所以他带你出去喝酒了。这是真的吗？是的。什么？
Yes. I was nervous about this episode because Pam had to be drunk. And that's hard to play and not be goofy. It is. And I confided in the writers and I said, I'm nervous. I don't know how to do it. And Mindy had a great stage direction later where she was saying, you know, Pam is nodding along.
是的。我当时对这一集感到很紧张，因为帕姆必须喝醉。这很难演好又不会显得滑稽。确实。我向编剧吐露了心声，我说我很紧张。我不知道该怎么演。敏迪后来有一个很棒的舞台调度，她说（你知道的，帕姆一直在点头）。
I loved that. Nodding. That was in the script that Pam is nodding when she's really drunk. Right. Paying attention. Yes. Yeah. Exactly.
我喜欢那个。点头。剧本里就写着帕姆喝醉时会点头。没错。表示注意力集中。是的。是的。没错。
I'm a normal person paying attention. Yes. Look how I am nodding at you. Yeah. So that was Mindy's stage direction. But the rest of it, like how do you gradually become drunk? And I was really afraid that I was going to do just some horrible, fake, drunky performance. You did fantastic.
我是一个注意力集中的正常人。是的。看我是怎么对你点头的。是的。所以那是敏迪的舞台调度。但其余的，比如你如何逐渐变得喝醉？我真的很担心我会做出某种可怕的、虚假的醉酒表演。你表现得棒极了。
Thank you. So BJ and I get to talking and we decide how about we go out, I'll have some drinks and BJ will ask me questions and help me observe what it feels like to slowly get drunk. So he was sort of going to document you having drinks. Yes. This is really messy. This is super nerdy. I like it though.
谢谢。所以BJ和我聊了起来，我们决定出去走走，我会喝点酒，而BJ会问我问题，并帮我观察慢慢变醉是什么感觉。所以他有点像是要记录你喝酒的过程。是的。这真的很乱。这超级书呆子气。不过我挺喜欢的。
And I know why I didn't take you out because I would have been the one also being like, I'll have drinks too. And like, no, this defeats the purpose. No. This is a scientific experiment. Yeah. So yeah. So I went out with BJ and it was really interesting because after the first two drinks, I was like,
而且我知道我为什么没带你出去，因为我也会是那种说“我也要喝一杯”的人，然后就会觉得，不，这背后的意义就没了。不。这是一项科学实验。是的。所以，是的。我和BJ一起出去了，这真的很有趣，因为在前两杯酒之后，我就觉得，
oh, I just feel buzzed and a little dizzy. I was laughing a lot. So that's why I had Pam do all of those ridiculous laughs in the episode. But by drink number four, I was drinking Cosmopolitan's. Oh my gosh, Jenna, did you get sick? I didn't get sick. Oh, good Lord. I know.
哦，我只是觉得有点微醺，有点头晕。我一直在笑。所以这就是为什么我在这一集里让潘做出所有那些荒谬的笑声。但到了第四杯时，我在喝大都会鸡尾酒。哦天哪，珍娜，你喝吐了吗？我没吐。哦，天呐。我知道。
So by drink number four, apparently I said to BJ, I don't feel drunk at all. I feel normal. And BJ said, really, because you're talking really loud and really close and you almost just fell over. And I was like, I did. So I stopped after drink number four, but I thought that it was really interesting how after so many drinks, I doubted that I was even drunk. Yes.
所以到了第四杯时，显然我对BJ说，我一点也不觉得醉。我觉得我很正常。BJ说，真的吗，因为你说话声音很大，离得极近，而且你刚才差点摔倒。然后我说，我有吗？所以我喝完第四杯就停下了，但我觉得很有意思的是，喝了那么多酒之后，我竟然怀疑自己到底有没有醉。是的。
And so all that information, I kind of weaved into my performance. Well it worked, lady. Thank you. I'm glad you didn't have a hangover. So folks, drink responsibly. Yeah. Don't drink for Cosmos. Yeah.
所以所有这些信息，我某种程度上都融入到了我的表演中。好吧，这很管用，女士。谢谢。我很高兴你没有宿醉。所以各位，饮酒要适度。是的。别为了喝大都会而喝。是的。
Don't drink for Cosmos. We do not recommend. Rain got really into the sound effects on that keyboard. He did. You remember that? I do. So they had a keyboard for him and they told him the different sounds the keyboard made. This is like handing a child like a keyboard or it's like even even when you give Rain
别为了大都会而喝。我们不推荐。雷恩对那个键盘的音效真的很着迷。他是的。你还记得吗？我记得。所以他们为他准备了一个键盘，并告诉他键盘能发出哪些不同的音效。这就像把一个键盘交到一个孩子手里，或者甚至，甚至当你给雷恩
a microphone. Oh yeah. Get ready because he's going to have a lot of bits. They told him he could play it whenever he wanted during Michael's speeches. And did he ever, I mean right out of the gate when Michael's like, well, Stanley, I can't wait to meet your wife. And he's like, I'm holding her hand right now. That was Rain improvising like, brrr, brrr.
一个麦克风。哦，是的。准备好吧，因为他会有很多即兴段子。他们告诉他，在迈克尔演讲期间，他可以随时弹奏。他真的弹了吗，我是说一开场当迈克尔说，哦，斯坦利，我等不及要见你妻子了。然后他说，我正抓着她的手呢。那是雷恩即兴发挥的，比如，嘟嘟。
Yeah. That was just Rain having fun on the keyboard. There was also an oh yeah, that he used to play. Oh my gosh. And Rain kept doing it at the most inappropriate moments. Because that was the thing that would make Steve break more than anything else. It wasn't the fart noise or the trumpet sounds. It was that oh yeah button.
是的。那只是雷恩在键盘上玩得开心而已。还有一个他经常弹的“哦，耶”。哦，天哪。而且雷恩一直在最不合时宜的时刻弹它。因为那是比任何事情都更能让史蒂夫笑场的东西。不是放屁声或小号声。而是那个“哦，耶”按钮。
And there was one time where Steve broke down laughing. It felt like 10 minutes if he could not get it back. He doubled over. We had to stop filming because he got so tickled because Rain kept hitting that oh yeah button. And Steve never breaks. He is a rock. He and Oscar are the two. Oh.
有一次史蒂夫笑得崩溃了。感觉就像有10分钟，他根本无法恢复状态。他笑得直不起腰。我们不得不停止拍摄，因为他被逗得太厉害了，而雷恩一直在按那个“哦，耶”按钮。而且史蒂夫从不笑场。他是一块岩石。他和奥斯卡是那两个。哦。
It is very hard to make either of them break. Oh, I would say they were statues for a long time. I was like, Oscar, are you a robot? Let's get into the awards. There were seven Dundee's given out at this awards. I'm sure there were more given out. But what we witnessed were seven. There was the busiest beaver, which was the busiest beaver to Phyllis.
要让他们两个任何一个笑场都非常难。哦，我会说他们俩很长一段时间里就像雕像一样。我当时想，奥斯卡，你是个机器人吗？让我们进入颁奖环节。这次颁奖典礼颁出了七个邓迪奖。我确信还颁出了更多。但我们目睹的是七个。一个是“最忙碌的海狸”奖，颁给了菲利斯。
There was hottest in the office to Ryan the temp, awkward. There was the tight ass award given to my character. Because not only is she's everybody's favorite stickler, she also has a great caboose. The spicy curry award given to Kelly. And it was actually a bowling award because they had run out of the little men holding briefcases. So she got a bowler. And then number five went to Kevin for the don't go in there after me award.
还有一个是颁给临时工瑞恩的“办公室最性感”奖，真尴尬。还有一个是颁给我这个角色的“小气鬼”奖。因为她不仅是每个人最喜欢的死板教条主义者，她还有一个极棒的翘臀。颁给凯利的“辣咖喱”奖。这其实是一个保龄球奖杯，因为他们用完了那种拿着公文包的小人。所以她拿到了一个保龄球。然后第五个颁给了凯文，得奖的是“别在我后面进那间屋子”奖。
Here's the interesting thing about that. If you look at that Dundee, it's actually a little guy squatting, but it was actually a weightlifting award. And they took the dumbbell out of the guy's hands. Oh, that's so smart. So that's what Kevin gets. And then number six is the fine work award given to Stanley. And number seven, of course, is the widest sneakers award given to Pam, which brings
关于这个奖，有趣的是。如果你看看那个邓迪奖杯，其实是一个蹲着的小人，但它原本是一个举重奖。他们把那个家伙手里的哑铃拿掉了。哦，太聪明了。所以这就是凯文得到的。然后第六个是颁给斯坦利的“杰出工作”奖。第七个，当然是颁给潘的“最大运动鞋”奖，这让
the house down. So a lot of fans asked this, specifically Courtney asked, what Dundee did Jim get? This is the first Dundee ceremony. We never see him get his award. Jim gets the Jim Helpert Award. That was his Dundee. He's just being Jim Helpert. Yeah, it got cut out, but Jim got the Jim Helpert Award.
全场轰动。所以很多粉丝都问了这个问题，特别是考特尼问的，吉姆得到了什么邓迪奖？这是第一届邓迪奖典礼。我们从没看到他领奖。吉姆得到了“吉姆·哈尔珀特奖”。那就是他的邓迪奖。他只是在做吉姆·哈尔珀特。是的，这个镜头被剪掉了，但吉姆确实得到了“吉姆·哈尔珀特奖”。
That's awesome. So strange. I think, I think Michael just thinks Jim is cool. Yeah. So you just get an award for being you. Correct. Please be my friend. So you talked about Ryan the temp gets the hottest in the office award.
太棒了。太奇怪了。我觉得，我觉得迈克尔只是觉得吉姆很酷。是的。所以你只是因为做你自己就得了一个奖。没错。请做我的朋友。所以你谈到临时工瑞恩获得了“办公室最性感”奖。
He has that great talking head then where he's being asked what he's going to do with his award. And he's like, I don't, that is the least of my worries right now. Well when Greg would direct, he would often pull us aside and interview us on the fly. And that talking head was an improvisation. Nice, BJ. BJ improvised that. That is awesome.
他随后有一个非常棒的单人访谈镜头，当时别人问他打算怎么处置这个奖。他说，我不知道，那是我现在最不担心的事情。好吧，当格雷格执导时，他经常把我们拉到一边，即兴采访我们。而那个单人访谈镜头是一次即兴发挥。干得好，BJ。这是BJ即兴发挥的。太棒了。
I have some really random cards. When you're ready for random Jenna, I don't want to mess up your list over there. All right. But when you're ready for random, I have some random cards. I'm ready. You know what? Why don't we take a break and then we'll come back to your random cards and some more info. Really sell it.
我有一些非常随机的卡片。当你准备好听随机内容时，珍娜，我不想搞乱你那边的清单。好的。但当你准备好听随机内容时，我有一些随机卡片。我准备好了。你知道吗？我们为什么不休息一下，然后再回过头来看你的随机卡片和更多信息呢。真会推销。
My fancy random cards. Yeah guys, stay with us so you can hear a bunch of random stuff. Hey. Hey guys, we're back. Are you ready for some random facts, Angela? All right. Here's some random. I love you, but at nine minutes, 53 seconds, you pick your teeth and I think you did it
我那些华丽的随机卡片。是的，大家，请留下来，这样你们就能听到一堆随机的事情了。嘿。嘿，伙计们，我们回来了。安吉拉，你准备好听一些随机的事实了吗？好的。这里有一些随机的。我爱你，但在9分53秒时，你在剔牙，我觉得你是
on purpose. I think it's Creed. You just let your freak fly and you're like, you know what, I'm picking my teeth. It's on camera. It's all good. I love me some Creed. At nine minutes, 58 seconds, I do an enormous Angela eye roll because Michael tells this very lame drunk driving joke right about spilling his drink and I do it a massive eye roll
故意的。我觉得那是克里德。你只是释放了你内心的怪异，然后心想，你知道吗，我在剔牙。这在镜头里。这都没关系。我超爱克里德。在9分58秒时，我翻了一个巨大的白眼，因为迈克尔讲了一个非常无聊的酒驾笑话，就在他洒了酒的时候，我翻了一个巨大的白眼，
and I have been sent that eye roll. People text it to me. Are you a meme? I might be. I guess I'm an eye roll meme, but yeah. That's exciting. That's exciting. This guy's hanging with me.
而且那个翻白眼的镜头被发给我过。人们把它发短信给我。你成了一个表情包吗？我可能是吧。我想我是一个白眼表情包，但是是的。这太令人兴奋了。这太令人兴奋了。这家伙一直陪着我。
This could be horrible, but I became obsessed. You know what happens? I get obsessed. So everyone is sitting at tables that kind of make sense, right? You can sort of see how there's the work friendships. For example, Kelly and Toby are at a table at the Chili's. Roy, Pam, and Daryl sit together, Ryan and Jim. When Ryan isn't holding up Michael's cue cards, he goes and sits with Jim.
这可能会很糟糕，但我变得有点着迷了。你知道会发生什么吗？我变得着迷了。所以每个人都坐在那些多少有点合乎逻辑的桌子旁，对吧？你可以大致看出工作中的友谊是怎样的。例如，凯利和托比坐在奇利餐厅的一张桌子旁。罗伊、潘和达里尔坐在一起，瑞恩和吉姆坐在一起。当瑞恩没有帮迈克尔拿提示卡时，他就会去和吉姆坐在一起。
This is before Pam comes back, right? Sure. To the beginning. Creed and Meredith sit together. Stanley is with his wife, Terry. Kevin, I think, is with his fiance, Stacey. Stacey. Stacey.
这是在潘回来之前，对吧？当然。在开头。克里德和梅雷迪思坐在一起。斯坦利和他的妻子特里在一起。凯文，我想，和他的未婚妻斯黛西在一起。斯黛西。斯黛西。
Stacey. And Angela's in the corner with Phyllis, but where is Oscar? Where is Oscar? Who is Oscar sitting with? I ask myself. Well. Well. And at 11 minutes, three seconds, you see that Oscar is sitting between a woman and a
斯黛西。安吉拉和菲利斯坐在角落里，但奥斯卡在哪儿？奥斯卡在哪儿？奥斯卡和谁坐在一起？我问我自己。好吧。好吧。在11分3秒时，你看到奥斯卡坐在一个女人和一个
man. The woman has long dark hair. Then at 15 minutes, nine seconds, I'm sitting next to Oscar in the booth and Oscar sitting behind me. And then at 15 minutes, 40 seconds, there's a new man and woman in the booth with Oscar and myself. What is happening? I don't know.
男人中间。那个女人留着长黑发。然后在15分09秒时，我和奥斯卡并排坐在卡座里，奥斯卡坐在我身后。接着在15分40秒时，卡座里多了一个新男人和一个新女人，和奥斯卡以及我坐在一起。这到底是怎么回事？我不知道。
And then at 15 minutes, 52 seconds, Oscar is between back between the original woman and man. Then at 17 minutes, 38 seconds, there's a new woman with dark hair and an updo sitting next to Oscar. I don't know. I don't. It's like, he's like, between this woman and man, then it's like this random woman, this random man, then Oscar than me, then it's Oscar back between this woman and man,
然后到了15分52秒，奥斯卡又坐回了最初那个女人和男人中间。接着在17分38秒时，一个留着黑发、盘着头发的新女人坐在了奥斯卡旁边。我不知道。我不知道。这就好像，他一会儿在这个女人和男人中间，一会儿又是这个随机的女人、随机的男人，然后是奥斯卡，然后是我，然后奥斯卡又回到了这个女人和男人中间，
but it happens within seconds. So like what kind of magic is Oscar doing and me? We're like hopping all over these booths. Do you have a recollection from when we taped the episode that they were moving you around? Well, I do. I do. And one shot, they needed to establish a reaction of everyone. And in order to do that in one sweeping pan shot, they had to stack some of us.
但这都是在几秒钟内发生的。所以，奥斯卡和我到底在搞什么魔法？我们就像在这些卡座里到处乱跳一样。对于我们拍摄这一集时他们把你移来移去这件事，你还有印象吗？哦，我有的。我有的。在一个镜头中，他们需要展现每个人的反应。为了在一个横摇镜头中做到这一点，他们不得不把我们中的一些人堆叠在一起。
So they moved me from my corner booth and they stuck me in front of Oscar in his booth and they pulled these other two people out. But in watching it, it's so funny to me because it's like Oscar keeps entertaining, he keeps having all these different people at his booth in a matter of seconds. Like we couldn't have physically all been up and down and back and forth like that. And then at the very end, Oscar leaves the chilies with the original couple. Wow. What is that with?
所以他们把我从角落的卡座里移开，把我塞到奥斯卡卡座里的奥斯卡前面，然后把另外两个人拉开了。但在观看的时候，这对我来说太搞笑了，因为感觉就像奥斯卡一直在招待客人，在短短几秒钟内，他的卡座里不断有各种不同的人。我们不可能在物理上像那样上下、前后地跑来跑去。然后到了最后，奥斯卡和最初的那对夫妇一起离开了奇利餐厅。哇。这到底是怎么回事？
I know guys. And who are those people? I don't know. We never find out. We never find out. We don't know. But anyway, it just cracked me up because I would look back there and I'd be like, oh, who's Oscar sitting with?
我知道，伙计们。那些人是谁？我不知道。我们从来没有弄清楚。我们从来没有弄清楚。我们不知道。但不管怎样，这让我觉得很好笑，因为我会回头看后面，然后心想，哦，奥斯卡在和谁坐在一起？
What? What? What? What? But it was like a matter of seconds. Wow. Now here's the thing. If you're watching just Oscar's booth, you're missing a lot of action that you probably should
什么？什么？什么？什么？但这只是几秒钟的事。哇。现在关键是，如果你只盯着奥斯卡的卡座，你就会错过很多你本该
be paying attention to. But I watched this episode three times prepping for this, so I watched it once just as me. You clearly watched it once just to see what Oscar was doing. I clearly watched it once just to see what was happening in the background. I think something we should talk about is Pam and Roy fighting in the parking lot. Yes. Let's talk about that. They originally said that they were not going to use the audio from this because there was
予以关注的精彩动作。但我为了筹备这一集把这集看了三遍，所以我看了一遍只是为了看我自己。你显然看了一遍只是为了看奥斯卡在做什么。我显然看了一遍只是为了看背景里发生了什么。我觉得我们应该谈谈的一件事是潘和罗伊在停车场争吵。是的。我们来谈谈这个。他们最初说他们不打算使用这里的音频，因为
no dialogue. In the script, it just said spy shot. Pam and Roy are having a heated argument in the parking lot. Roy tugs her arm, Pam pulls away, and heads back into the restaurant. Roy slams the truck door, then gets in the other side. And that was it. Yeah. So David and I improvised a fight that we were having, and then they used it.
没有对话。剧本里只写了“偷拍镜头”。潘和罗伊在停车场发生激烈争吵。罗伊拉扯她的手臂，潘挣脱开，径直走回餐厅。罗伊砰地关上卡车门，然后坐到另一边。就这些。是的。所以大卫和我即兴发挥了一场我们俩的争吵，然后他们就采用了。
Yeah. So that was so crazy. That is crazy. And I love what Pam said when she was like, you know, if you had listened, you would have known that. Of course, we don't know what you're talking about, right? But I was like, when Roy grabbed your arm, I was like, hey, hey, no, I know. He gets a little physical with her sometimes with the grabbing of the arm.
是的。所以这太疯狂了。这太疯狂了。我喜欢潘说的那句话，当她说，“你知道，如果你当时听了，你就会知道了。”当然，我们不知道你在说什么，对吧？但当时我就想，当罗伊抓你的手臂时，我就想，嘿，嘿，不，我知道。他有时对她确实有点肢体接触，比如抓手臂什么的。
Someone mentioned that. And he's a big guy. He is. So you sort of really see in that moment that Pam has just fed up and she wants to stay and she wants to be with her friends. And I think she wants to be with another person. I don't know what you're talking about. Yeah.
有人提到过这一点。而且他是个大块头。他是。所以你在那一刻真的能看出潘已经受够了，她想留下来，她想和她的朋友们在一起。而且我认为她想和另一个人在一起。我不知道你在说什么。是的。
I think she wants to be with Jim, who she sits down at a table with. I know. And the look on his face when you come back in, oh, he is so delighted she starts drinking his beer immediately. I know. And then she orders her own drinks and it leads us into a famous line. Who knew it would be this famous written by Mindy Kaling? Look what I have on my note card.
我觉得她想和吉姆在一起，她坐到了吉姆的桌子旁。我知道。当你走回来时，他脸上的表情，哦，他是那么高兴，她立刻开始喝他的啤酒。我知道。然后她点了自己的酒，这就引出了一句著名的台词。谁知道由明迪·卡aling写出的这句台词会这么有名？看我笔记本上写了什么。
It's like second drink. Second drink. Yes. And Andrew Nelson asked, did you add Lib's second drink or was it scripted? It was scripted. And a lot of people asked about what are we really drinking? Is it really alcohol? No.
就像“第二杯酒”。第二杯酒。是的。安德鲁·纳尔逊问，你加了“莉布的第二杯酒”还是剧本里本来就有？剧本里本来就有。很多人都在问我们真正喝的是什么？真的是酒精吗？不。
No. We would be so wasted. No, it looks like something from like a Nickelodeon slime, like a word show. Because like, do you see, like, if you look at Meredith's drink, it's like a neon green. Yeah. What was she drinking? I don't know. But I think they really wanted the drinks to pop so you could see them.
不。我们早就喝醉了。不，它看起来像是尼克国际儿童频道的史莱姆，或者某种动画秀里的东西。因为你看，如果你看看梅雷迪思的饮料，它是一种霓虹绿色。是的。她喝的是什么？我不知道。但我认为他们真的很想让饮料的颜色跳出来，这样你就能看得到。
And so they added a lot of like food dye and things. Well, the beer is usually just non-alcoholic beer. So the beer actually tastes like beer. And you feel bloaty. Yeah. And I don't like beer and I don't like the taste of beer. So I hate it whenever I have to drink it on camera because bleh. And then other drinks like wine, it's usually watered down juice.
所以他们添加了大量的食用色素之类的东西。好吧，啤酒通常只是无酒精啤酒。所以啤酒尝起来确实像啤酒。而且你会觉得腹胀。是的。我不喜欢啤酒，我也不喜欢啤酒的味道。所以我讨厌任何时候必须在镜头前喝它，因为太难喝了。然后其他饮料，比如葡萄酒，通常是兑了水的果汁。
Cranberry juice. Mm-hmm. Apple juice. Yeah. And then the other drinks are anything, sometimes it's just water with a little food coloring in it. Or like if it is supposed to look like a bourbon or something, it could just be tea. Oh, yeah.
蔓越莓汁。嗯嗯。苹果汁。是的。然后其他饮料可以是任何东西，有时只是加了一点食用色素的水。或者如果它需要看起来像波本威士忌或其他什么，它可能只是茶。哦，是的。
Mm-hmm. Yeah. Sometimes they'll brew you some tea and pour it over ice. And then now you have. I'm actually happy when you have that. Like if you have a Long Island iced tea and you're just drinking an iced tea. Yeah. Sam just pulled up for you guys listening a whole page on the internet of just me rolling
嗯嗯。是的。有时他们会给你冲泡一些茶，然后加冰。然后你就有。如果你拿着一杯长岛冰茶，而你其实只是在喝冰茶，我其实会很高兴。是的。萨姆刚刚为收听节目的你们调出了互联网上满满一页全部都是我翻
my eyes and looking snarky. So as Angela Martin, I guess there's a lot of snarky eye roll options out there are just snarky looks. They're not limited to the dundies. Okay, Sam, take it down. I can't look at myself rolling my eyes at myself. So now we get into the tender moment where Michael is desperately trying to keep the dundies going and the guys at the bar start to heckle him.
白眼和看起来刻薄的照片。所以作为安吉拉·马丁，我想有很多刻薄的翻白眼选择，或者只是刻薄的表情。它们并不局限于邓迪奖。好了，萨姆，拿下去吧。我不能看着自己对翻白眼的我翻白眼。现在我们进入了温馨的时刻，迈克尔拼命地想要把邓迪奖颁奖典礼继续下去，而吧台的人开始起哄。
Yeah. He's so wounded. And Pam won't have it. Well, I think it's that moment. Even there's a look that comes across Jim's face of like, oh, like that, that's mean, you know? Yeah. And it's sort of that thing of like, you know, you're a creepy cousin that creeps everyone
是的。他深受打击。而潘可不答应。好吧，我觉得就是那一刻。吉姆的脸上甚至闪过一种表情，心想，“哦，像那样，这也太卑鄙了吧，你知道吗？”是的。这有点像是，你知道的，你有一个让人毛骨悚然的表亲，他让所有人都觉得
out, but you have to take up for them because they're your cousin. It's like that moment of like, okay, he's like family and we get to like make fun of them, but no one else can. That's right. And Pam starts chanting dundies and getting people to rally around him. And I love that. And this is a little bit the relationship between Pam and Michael. This is the way that she shows up for him, the way he shows up for her at her art show
毛骨悚然，但你必须为他撑腰，因为他是你的表亲。这就好像那种时刻，好吧，他就像是家人，我们可以取笑他，但别人不行。没错。然后潘开始带领大家高喊“邓迪奖”，并让大家团结在他周围。我太喜欢这个了。这也是潘和迈克尔之间关系的一种体现。这就是她为他挺身而出的方式，就像后来在她艺术展上他为她挺身而出一样。
later. Yeah. Like in their lowest moments, they are there for one another. When Pam gives him a hug when she gets her dundie, his face is so precious. He's just like, it's like the whole night was made in that moment. So Pam, accepting her dundie is another famous line. Yes. I feel God in this chilies tonight.
是的。就像在他们最糟糕的时刻，他们都在彼此身边。当潘在拿到邓迪奖时拥抱他时，他的表情太珍贵了。他简直就像是，感觉整个夜晚都是为了那一刻而存在的。所以潘接受她的邓迪奖是另一句名言。是的。我今晚在这个奇利餐厅感受到了上帝。
Oh, I love it. So when I rewatched this, there was this moment I wrote on my note card because when you say I'd like to thank God for this dundie, it cuts to Jim and Jim's reaction to you thanking God for your dundie is one of the best moments for me of the whole episode. It is just so sweet. He's just looking at you like, oh, my sweet little drunk friend, I love you. Well I talked to Mindy about this on the day and she had told me that Greg did not have total confidence in Pam thanking God for her dundie, but we were going to do it anyway.
哦，我太喜欢了。所以当我重温这一集时，有这么一个时刻我写在了我的笔记本上，因为当你说了“我要感谢上帝赐予我这个邓迪奖”时，镜头切到了吉姆，吉姆对你感谢上帝获得邓迪奖的反应对我来说是整集中最好的时刻之一。这真是太甜蜜了。他只是看着你，仿佛在说，“哦，我可爱的小醉鬼朋友，我爱你。”好吧，我在当天和明迪谈过这个，她告诉我，格雷格对潘感谢上帝获得邓迪奖并没有十足的信心，但我们无论如何都要这么做。
He was a little bit like, I don't totally get it. And she's like, no, you know, like whenever people win awards or they have like big sports moments. Yeah. A lot of times they thank God. And I asked her, I said, but how do I do it because, and she said, you do it totally sincerely. Yeah.
他当时有点觉得，我不是太明白这个梗。而她说，不，你知道的，每当人们赢得奖项或者他们有重大的体育时刻时。是的。很多时候他们都会感谢上帝。我问她，我说，那我该怎么演呢，因为，她说，你要表现得无比真诚。是的。
She's like, you really are like sincerely thankful and grateful for your dundie tonight. It totally made sense to me because I felt like drunk Pam thinks this is what you do when you win an award. That's right. You take a moment, you thank God. Then you scream, woohoo. Yeah. And I loved it so much.
她说，你今晚真的对你的邓迪奖感到由衷的感谢和感恩。这对我来说完全说得通，因为我觉得喝醉的潘认为，当你赢得一个奖项时，这就是你该做的事。没错。你花点时间，感谢上帝。然后你尖叫一声，呜呼。是的。我太喜欢了。
And then after this, after she gets her dundie, Pam kisses Jim on the lips. I know. I know. Was that weird? So this was a big fan question, Caitlin asked, do you consider this episode as Pam and Jim's first kiss or do you think it's casino night? I did not consider this their first kiss. I did.
然后在这之后，在潘拿到邓迪奖后，潘亲了吉姆的嘴唇。我知道。我知道。这很奇怪吗？所以这是一个很大的粉丝问题，凯特琳问，你认为这一集是潘和吉姆的初吻，还是你觉得是“赌场之夜”那一集？我不认为这是他们的初吻。我认为是。
John did. I disagree. I consider it. You planted one on him. The intention there was that it was accidental. The intention was that Pam was going for his cheek and it was one of those moments where he moved his head in a way that I wasn't expecting and I'm drunk and I just followed through. That was what was in my head as Pam.
约翰也是这么认为的。我不同意。我认为是。你强吻了他。那里的意图是它是偶然的。本意是潘原本是冲着他的脸颊去的，而那是那种他移动头部的方式出乎我的意料的时刻，而且我喝醉了，我就顺势亲下去了。这就是作为潘的我脑子里的想法。
So I wasn't thinking that I was intending to kiss his lips. And so Pam kind of doesn't register it. That was me. John said that Jim, who is not drunk, was very aware that they just kissed on the lips. And this was a whole conversation that we had off camera. I agree with him, though, and I see both sides. I see as a drunk person, you just kind of hug and you're a little sloppy. Yeah.
所以我当时并没有想要去亲他的嘴唇。所以潘其实并没有意识到这一点。那是我的想法。约翰说吉姆当时没喝醉，他非常清楚他们刚刚嘴对嘴亲吻了。这是我们在镜头外进行的一场长篇大论。不过我同意他的看法，而且我能理解双方。我能理解作为一个喝醉的人，你可能只是拥抱一下，动作有点毛手毛脚。是的。
But I see for him as a sober person, this person he's in love with just kissed him. Yeah. But it was unintentional on Pam's part in her mind. I know. But a lot of people wrote in and said, oh my gosh, why didn't everyone in the office? Why wasn't this a big gossipy moment? They know Pam's engaged and they all witnessed her kiss Jim. And in my mind, it was because it wasn't really a kiss.
但我能理解对他来说作为一个清醒的人，这个他深爱的人刚刚亲了他。是的。但在潘的心里，她并不是故意的。我知道。但很多人写信来问，哦天哪，为什么办公室里的其他人没有？为什么这不是一个充满八卦的时刻？他们知道潘订婚了，而且他们都亲眼目击她亲了吉姆。而在我看来，那是因为那其实算不上一个吻。
It wasn't a... Oh, well, in my mind, everyone was talking about it at work. Trust me. Oh, okay. Over and accounting. Because I tell you what. Angela Martin was sitting with Phyllis in a booth when that happened. And I'm pretty sure she was like, mm-hmm, did you see the office mattress just to smooch
那不是一个……哦，好吧，在我看来，办公室里的每个人都在谈论这件事。相信我。哦，好吧。在财务部那边。因为我告诉你。当那件事发生时，安吉拉·马丁正和菲利斯坐在卡座里。而且我敢肯定她当时的想法是，嗯哼，你看到那个办公室的公共交际花又去跟别人亲热了吗？
someone else? Well, I have another fan question for you then. This one is from Amy. She said, at the end, when you drive Pam home, in my mind, Angela would be so disgusted by Pam's behavior, it seems odd that she would give her a ride. Well, let me tell you, Amy, if you watch the deleted scenes, because I did, you will see that Angela Martin has a talking head where she is the company's designated driver. And you would know that Angela Martin would take this very serious as the safety officer
好吧，那我还有一个粉丝问题要问你。这个是艾米问的。她说，最后当你开车送潘回家时，在我的想象中，安吉拉应该对潘的行为感到无比恶心，她居然会送她回家，这看起来很奇怪。好吧，让我告诉你，艾米，如果你看了删减片段，因为我看过，你就会看到安吉拉·马丁有一个单人访谈镜头，在镜头里她是公司的指定代驾。而且你会知道安吉拉·马丁作为邓德米夫林的
for Dunder Mifflin. And I have this talking head where Angela goes on to say, and you know what, no one gives me any gas money, and everyone lives all over. It's very expensive. Wow. That is gold. So she's always the martyr. She's doing her job, but no one gives her gas money, and she has to drive these drunks
安全官，会把这看得非常严肃。而且我有一个单人访谈镜头，安吉拉在里面接着说，“而且你知道吗，根本没人给我油钱，大家还住得到处都是。这油费老贵了。”哇。这简直是金句。所以她总是扮演殉道者。她在做她的工作，但没人给她油钱，她还得开车到处送这些醉鬼，
around, but she's the designated driver, and so she has to do it. So not only did Pam probably not give her any gas money, she was very disappointed in her behavior. And Angela quietly judged her the whole drive and probably told her, you need to make some new life choices. Amy also wanted to know, was that really you driving? Yes, it was. At 20 minutes, two seconds in the car, you see my shoulder.
但她是指定代驾，所以她不得不这么做。所以潘不仅可能没给她油钱，而且她对潘的行为非常失望。安吉拉在整个车程中都在默默地评判她，并且可能对她说，你需要重塑你的人生选择了。艾米还想知道，真的是你在开车吗？是的，确实是我。在20分02秒时，在车里，你能看到我的肩膀。
Now here's the thing, they wanted me every time in the car, you got in with me every time I pulled away, and then I would back up and we'd do the scene over a few times. And I had a front row seat watching Pam and Jim have that sort of very tender but awkward moment where Pam has a question for him, but then notices the camera. I watched that whole thing over and over as you guys did it, and it was so great. You guys did such a fantastic job. And when I rewatched it, part of me was like, well, why'd they have me in the car? You don't see me anyway.
事情是这样的，每次在车里，他们都要求我在车里，每次我把车开走时你都上车，然后我会倒车，我们把这个场景拍了好几遍。而且我坐在前排，看着潘和吉姆上演那种非常温柔但又尴尬的时刻，当时潘有个问题想问他，但随后注意到了摄像机。当你们俩拍这一幕时，我把整个过程看了一遍又一遍，真是太棒了。你们俩的表现太出色了。当我重温这一集时，我内心的一部分会想，好吧，他们为什么非得让我在车里？反正你也看不见我。
But they didn't know. As you know, with our show, we always had an A camera and a B camera, and they would be sort of carving up the scene, and there might be this moment where they whipped around and could have seen me. So they wanted to make sure I was there just in case, and I was happy to be there. But also, I had... Yeah, a lot of times they would use a double for that in other shows. But in our show, we were our own doubles.
但他们不知道。正如你所知，在我们的节目中，我们总是有A摄像机和B摄像机，它们会把这个场景拆分拍摄，而且可能会有某个时刻它们转过来刚好能拍到我。所以他们想确保我在那里以防万一，而且我也很高兴能在那里。但同时，我有……是的，其他很多节目会用替身来拍这个。但在我们的节目中，我们自己就是自己的替身。
That's right, because as a documentary, you really never knew where that second camera would end up landing, and you could end up on camera. I was asked, is that a cat air freshener hanging from your rear view mirror in your car? Is it? It looks like it could be a cat or a tree. Guys, I don't know, I tried to zoom in on it. Oh, I hope it's a cat. I hope it's a green cat.
没错，因为作为一部纪录片，你真的永远不知道第二台摄像机会停在哪里，你最终可能会入镜。有人问我，你车内的后视镜上挂着的是一只猫的空气清新剂吗？是吗？它看起来既像是一只猫，也像是一棵树。伙计们，我不知道，我试图把它放大。哦，我希望是只猫。我希望是只绿猫。
Let's call it a cat. I hope it's a green cat. A green cat doesn't sound right now, Angela. I know, but maybe it was a Christmas cat that I held on to. Not sure. Something we haven't talked about is the scene where Pam falls off the stool because she is so drunk, and this leads me into a fan question. Matt Sheldon asked, how did you get Chili's to cooperate with this idea?
我们就叫它猫吧。我希望是只绿猫。安吉拉，绿猫现在听起来可不太对劲。我知道，但也许那是我一直留着的圣诞猫呢。不确定。我们还没讨论的一件事是潘从凳子上摔下来的那一幕，因为她喝得太醉了，这让我想到了一个粉丝问题。马特·谢尔顿问，你们是怎么让奇利餐厅配合这个想法的？
Well, they were on the fence, and we almost weren't allowed to film there, remember? Well, here's what happened. Originally in the script, Pam vomits all over the bar. She does not fall off the stool. She is listening to Jim, she is nodding, and then she vomits. And we had been filming for two days, and I guess suddenly they had had Chili's permission. Chili's helped build the Chili's, and someone at Chili's read the script, finally. Well, I guess.
好吧，他们一开始还在犹豫，我们差一点就不被允许在那里拍摄了，还记得吗？好吧，事情是这样的。最初在剧本里，潘在吧台吐了一地。她没有从凳子上摔下来。她听着吉姆说话，点着头，然后就吐了。我们已经拍了两天了，我想突然之间他们拿到了奇利餐厅的许可。奇利餐厅参与了奇利餐厅的搭建，奇利餐厅里有人终于读了剧本。好吧，我猜是的。
And freaked out. I read the script. It wasn't fully complete. You know, they hadn't done their second pass, and so Chili's had not gotten all of the scenes, and so they didn't have the scene where Pam vomited, and all of this happened. Well, once they read that, they shut down the production. Yes, and we thought, what? They said, no way.
然后他们吓坏了。我读了剧本。它还没有完全完成。你知道的，他们还没有进行第二遍润色，所以奇利餐厅没有拿到所有的剧本场景，因此他们没有潘呕吐的那个场景，以及所有这些后续发生的事情。好吧，一旦他们读到那一幕，他们就叫停了制作。是的，我们当时想，什么？他们说，没门。
They were very nervous about the drinking and the drunkenness and the sort of way that that might reflect on Chili's. So Greg and Mindy started scrambling, and they came up with this idea that instead of vomiting, that Pam would fall off a stool. Right. And then also, I think it was Rain's idea to say, well, maybe Dwight could say, oh, she's had a seizure, and not the vomiting. And then the other part of it was that we had to write in a new element, which is that
他们对饮酒、醉酒以及这可能会对奇利餐厅产生的不良影响感到非常紧张。所以格雷格和明迪开始绞尽脑汁，他们想出了这个主意：与其让潘呕吐，不如让她从凳子上摔下来。没错。然后还有，我想那是雷恩的主意，他说，也许德怀特可以说，“哦，她癫痫发作了”，而不是呕吐。然后另一部分是，我们必须加入一个新的元素，那就是
Pam was going to get banned from Chili's. And the person who gives the speech in the episode was an actual Chili's manager franchise owner named John Bossert. He was not an actor. And they felt like by having an actual Chili's representative state very clearly the Chili's policy against over-serving and banning Pam for life, then they allowed us to film the rest of the episode. Yes.
潘将被奇利餐厅禁止入内。而在这集中发表讲话的那个人是奇利餐厅的一位真正的经理兼加盟店老板，名叫约翰·博瑟特。他不是演员。他们觉得，通过让一个真正的奇利餐厅代表非常明确地阐述奇利餐厅反对过度劝酒的政策并终身禁止潘入内，他们才会允许我们拍摄接下来的剧集。是的。
And they had Pam, they had you as Pam, waiter never brought you more drinks. You were reaching on other people's tables, so you were doing it, not Chili's. And you know what? I think that's great. I think that it was really important to Chili's that people know that they are responsible. And a family establishment. And a family establishment. And I love that John Bossert, an actual Chili's owner, got to do that talking head.
而且他们让潘，让你扮演的潘，服务员从没给你拿过更多的酒。你在够别人的桌上的酒，所以这是你干的，不是奇利餐厅干的。你知道吗？我觉得这太棒了。我觉得让奇利餐厅知道人们知道他们是负责任的，这一点非常重要。而且是一个适合家庭的场所。一个适合家庭的场所。我很高兴约翰·博瑟特这位真正的奇利餐厅老板能完成那个单人访谈镜头。
And I thought he did a fantastic job. He did great. He looked to camera when he was like, so she is banned. Like his little look to camera was fantastic. And also that aspect of Pam being banned for life was a wonderful thing that just grew into many more jokes. And I know, I loved it. I loved it.
而且我觉得他表现得太棒了。他表现得很棒。当他说“所以她被禁止入内”时，他看向镜头。他那个看镜头的眼神简直太棒了。而且潘被终身禁止入内这一设定也是一个精彩的转折，后来演变出了更多的笑话。我知道，我太喜欢了。我太喜欢了。
Pam is like such like, not a troublemaker. And she's banned from like a nationwide chain as if there is such a system that could control that. I know. I have one card that's sort of around that area. So can I talk about it right now? Sure. Once again, Rainn Wilson finds a way to take off his shirt.
潘看起来就像是个，完全不是个惹麻烦的人。然而她却被一家全国性的连锁店禁止入内，就好像真有能控制这种事的系统似的。我知道。我有一张卡片大致就是关于这部分的。所以我现在可以讲讲吗？当然。雷恩·威尔逊再次找到了脱掉衬衫的方法。
Always taking off his shirt. We're good to see his beautiful white flesh and belly. Because somehow that's going to help save Pam. It was going to be a pillow for your head. I guess so. Yeah. A lot of people asked about the falling off the stool moment. Was it scripted?
总是脱掉衬衫。我们有机会看到他美丽的白皙肉体和肚皮。因为不知怎么的，那能帮到拯救潘。那要当你的头枕。我想是吧。很多人问关于从凳子上摔下来那一幕。那是剧本里写好的吗？
Did I actually do it? It was scripted. I did actually do it. But again, like being drunk, I was very nervous about falling off the stool and making it look good. So Greg Daniels, he got on the stool and he showed me how he wanted me to fall. He said he wanted me to just keep looking at John and nodding and then slowly slip off the stool.
真的是我自己摔的吗？那是剧本里写好的。确实是我自己摔的。但同样地，由于是在假装喝醉，我很担心自己从凳子上摔下来时能不能摔得好看。所以格雷格·丹尼尔斯亲自坐到凳子上，向我展示他希望我怎么摔。他说他希望我一直看着约翰点头，然后慢慢地从凳子上滑下去。
And he's very large. He's very tall. He's tall. He's like six-two or something. Yeah. And so he fell down. They had padding on the floor. So he and I were both falling on padding.
而且他身材高大。他非常高。他很高。他大概有六尺二寸高或者别的什么。是的。所以他就摔倒了。他们在地上铺了垫子。所以他和我都摔在垫子上。
But John, Chris and Skyni, we kept pretending like we didn't understand how I should fall off the stool. On purpose to mess with Greg? So that Greg could have to keep showing us. Oh my gosh. You were like, that's the moment where you were like real Jim and Pam because you were breaking Greg the way you would prank Dwight. 100%.
但约翰、克里斯和斯基尼，我们一直假装我们不明白我该怎么从凳子上摔下来。故意捉弄格雷格？这样格雷格就不得不一遍又一遍地示范给我们看。哦，天哪。你们俩当时的状态，就是真正的吉姆和潘那种状态，因为你们捉弄格雷格的方式就像你们捉弄德怀特一样。百分之百。
Does Greg know that? He does. And then Greg told me later, I guess John and I told that story in an interview and he confronted us. He was like, guys, you know, I really hurt my back. No, he did not. So we were, then we felt so bad. Oh my God, you guys, you, that was real life Jim Pam moment.
格雷格知道这件事吗？他知道。后来格雷格告诉我，我想约翰和我在一次采访中讲了这个故事，然后他跑来质问我们。他说，“伙计们，你们知道的，我的背真的摔伤了。”不，他才没有呢。所以我们当时，然后我们觉得太糟糕了。哦，天哪，你们俩，你们，那真是现实生活中的吉姆和潘时刻。
It was. It was. But I love doing that. I love doing that stunt. I thought it ended up looking really good too. I was proud of it. I thought it looked fantastic. I thought that whole like part where you were nodding and then you were like, what?
确实是。确实是。但我喜欢拍那个。我喜欢那个特技动作。我觉得最后呈现出来的效果也真的很棒。我为之感到骄傲。我觉得看起来棒极了。我觉得你一边点头一边说“什么？”的那整个部分，
And he was like, what? And then you start laughing. It was so perfect. It was so perfect. This brings us to the scene with Jim in the parking lot that we were talking about a little bit earlier. A lot of people wanted to know what was Pam going to ask Jim. She wanted to bring up so many things.
然后他说“什么？”接着你开始笑。简直太完美了。简直太完美了。这就把我们带到了我们刚才稍微聊过的停车场与吉姆的那场戏。很多人想知道潘当时到底打算问吉姆什么。她想提起的事情实在太多了。
So I think that's what stopped her because there were so many options going through her head in that moment. And I had written out in my script, all of these things that I could possibly say so that I could in that moment rifle through them, but then not pick any of them. Right. I think it's that moment where you have so much to say and you're like, can I ask you a question? And then it would just, the floodgates would have opened, but you saw the camera and it
所以我想正是这个阻止了她，因为在那一刻，她的脑海里闪过了太多的选项。我在剧本里写下了所有我可能说的话，这样我就可以在那一刻在脑海里快速浏览它们，但最终什么都不选。对。我觉得那是那种你有太多话想说，然后你说，“我能问你个问题吗？”接着，情绪的闸门本该打开的，但你看到了摄像机，它
gave you sort of this like check of like, I can't do this, not here, not now. And I'm so glad that she didn't because those kind of drunken, confessional conversations, that wasn't going to lead to the right place. You know, I'm glad the camera was there for them in that moment because I think what Pam was going to say, what I had written in my script was something along the lines of, I love you. Well, I think the question was going to be, you know, do you think I should break up with Roy?
让你有了一种自省的感觉，心想，“我不能这么做，不能在这里，也不能在此时此地。”我很高兴她没有这么做，因为那种酒后倾诉式的对话，是不会通往正确的结果的。你知道的，我很高兴当时摄像机在那儿，因为我觉得潘当时想说的话，我在剧本里写的是类似于“我爱你”之类的话。好吧，我觉得那个问题大概会是，“你知道，你觉得我应该和罗伊分手吗？”
Yeah. What do you, do you think I'm with the wrong person? Yeah. Those kind of leading questions. Hoping that he'd say, you are be with me. Yes, exactly. So here's the crazy thing. We mentioned earlier that our second season only had six episodes picked up, that this
是的。你觉得，你觉得我和错的人在一起了吗？是的。那种带有引导性的问题。希望能听到他说“你应该跟我在一起”。是的，没错。所以最疯狂的事情是。我们前面提到过，我们的第二季只预订了六集，
was the third episode that we shot and we didn't know this was going to be the premiere of season two when we shot it. In fact, one of the ideas was that if we got canceled, it would be the season finale. And so I said to Greg, I think just in case we get canceled and this is the season finale, I think we should film an alternate ending to this scene in the parking lot where Pam does tell Jim how she feels and they kiss for real, not the Chili's kiss, but the real kiss just so that we could air it and we don't leave people hanging. And Greg said, no, he said, no, if they want to see what happens with Jim and Pam, they're
这是我们拍摄的第三集，我们在拍的时候并不知道这会是第二季的首播集。事实上，其中的一个想法是，如果我们被砍了，它就会成为季终集。所以我对格雷格说，我想以防万一我们被砍了，而这成了季终集，我觉得我们应该为停车场这场戏拍一个备用结局，在这个结局里，潘确实向吉姆表达了她的真实感受，他们真的接吻了，不是奇利餐厅那个吻，而是真正的吻，这样我们就可以把它播出来，不至于给观众留下悬念。格雷格说，不，他说，不，如果他们想看吉姆和潘之间会发生什么，他们
just going to have to order more episodes. I don't want to give them a choice. There you go. He was very protective of Jim and Pam and what went out in the world about that relationship. But that shows you how much we thought we were going to be canceled all the time. All the time. That I was pitching ideas for how to wrap up the whole series just in case. If you think that a normal show gets, well, at that time, Network TV, you would get 22
就只能要求预订更多的集数。我不想给他们选择的余地。就是这样。他对吉姆和潘以及关于这段关系的走向在世界上播出的内容保护得非常严。但这就向你展示了我们当时觉得自己随时都可能被砍的程度。随时随地。如果你认为一部正常的剧能够获得——好吧，在那个时候，电视网的剧，你通常能获得22
episodes and we got six. It doesn't make you feel like anyone's really confident about what you're doing. We didn't think NBC was like, oh, we got a winner here. I have some deleted scenes cards. Oh, tell them. Well, one of the ones I really loved is that Toby does a talking head where he says he's never won a Dundee. Oh, yeah.
集，而我们只有六集。这不会让你觉得任何人对你在做的事有什么真正的信心。我们当时不觉得NBC会想，“哦，我们这回挖到宝了”。我有一些关于删减片段的卡片。哦，快讲讲。好吧，我真的很喜欢的一个片段是，托比有一个单人访谈镜头，在里面他说他从未赢得过邓迪奖。哦，是的。
Michael refuses to give Toby a Dundee, just leaves him out every year. And now everyone in the office gets a Dundee, but Toby and I think, and Toby's like, I'm okay with that. I thought that was really funny. And then there's a great Dwight Angela scene at the copier where Dwight is really trying to force Angela to tell him what was written in the bathroom wall. And I'm like, I don't repeat those kind of things. It's inappropriate.
迈克尔拒绝给托比颁发邓迪奖，每年都把他落下。现在办公室里的每个人都得到了邓迪奖，除了托比，我想，而托比却觉得，我对此没意见。我觉得这真的太搞笑了。然后还有一个非常棒的德怀特和安吉拉在复印机旁的场景，德怀特真的在极力逼迫安吉拉告诉他洗手间的墙上写了什么。而我说，“我才不重复那种话呢。这太不合适了。”
I don't want to say those words out loud. And then Dwight's like, does it have anything to do with his butt or his wiener? And I just walk off in a huff. But it's the very first time I feel like Dwight and I have some little clandestine conversation just between the two of us. Oh, that's a good one. Yeah. Pam does confess that she wrote it on the wall.
我不想把那些词大声说出来。然后德怀特就说，“这跟他的屁股或者他的小弟弟有关吗？”然后我气呼呼地走开了。但这是我第一次觉得我和德怀特之间有了某种仅属于我们俩的秘密对话。哦，这个不错。是的。潘确实承认了那是她写在墙上的。
She does. About Michael, but we don't find out what it was. Which I love too. I love what she's like. I feel bad about what I wrote and he's like, no, you don't. People wanted to know, did we all get to keep our dundies? Yes, we did. Yes, we did.
她承认了。是关于迈克尔的，但我们不知道具体写了什么。我也很喜欢这一点。我喜欢她那种“我对写下的内容感到难过”的样子，而他说，“不，你才不难过呢”。人们想知道，我们所有人都保留了自己的邓迪奖吗？是的，我们保留了。是的，我们保留了。
We all have them. I have two. I have two as well. I have longest engagement and Dwight is sneakers. They gave me the longest engagement that you see me win in earlier years. I have the tight ass award. And then from years later, which we'll get to, I have the she's kind of a bitch. I think Pam doesn't get a dundee the second time around.
我们都有。我有两个。我也有两个。我有“最长恋情”奖和德怀特的“最大运动鞋”奖。他们把你在早年间看到的我赢得的“最长恋情”奖给了我。我有“小气鬼”奖。然后几年后，我们后面会讲到，我拿到了“她有点像个碧池”奖。我觉得潘第二次没有拿到邓迪奖。
I don't think so. There weren't as many that round. I have a final fan question. This is something for us to discuss, Angela. This is from Samantha. Okay. She says, the last two times I have watched this episode, which is one of my top five favorite episodes, we have immediately been hit by a tornado.
我不这么觉得。那轮没颁那么多奖。我还有一个最后的粉丝问题。安吉拉，这是需要我们讨论一下的事情。这是萨姆问的。好的。她说，我最近两次看这一集时——这是我最喜欢的五集之一——我们立刻就遭遇了龙卷风袭击。
What? Within 10 minutes of the line, I feel God in this chilies tonight. Samantha, first of all, where do you live? Do you think I'm jinxed or is it just bad luck? Should Samantha ever watch this episode again? I would say, do you live in tornado alley? Do you live in like Kansas, North Texas, Oklahoma? Like where?
什么？距离那句台词“我今晚在这个奇利餐厅感受到了上帝”还不到10分钟。萨姆，首先，你住在哪儿？你觉得我是被下了咒还是纯粹运势不佳？萨姆以后还应该再看这一集吗？我想说，你住在龙卷风走廊吗？你住在堪萨斯州、得克萨斯州北部、俄克拉荷马州吗？比如哪儿？
Where do you live? Right. And perhaps the next time you watch it, watch it in the storm cellar? Or maybe hit pause right before that line. Check the weather. Skip it. Just skip ahead and watch the end. And come back.
你住在哪里？对的。也许下次你看的时候，去风暴地窖里看？或者在那句台词之前按暂停。查一下天气。跳过它。直接快进看结尾。然后再回来。
That is a crazy coincidence. That is crazy. That was the craziest fan question we got. I had to include it because I found it so charming and I was a little worried about Samantha. So guys, before we go, we want to tell you about a new feature of the Office Ladies podcast called Office Ladies Candy Bag. Yes, it's over at Stitcher Premium.
这真是个疯狂的巧合。太疯狂了。这是我们收到的最疯狂的粉丝提问。我必须把它收录进来，因为我觉得它太迷人了，而且我有点担心萨曼莎。所以伙计们，在我们离开之前，我们要告诉大家《办公室女士》播客的一个新功能，叫做《办公室女士糖果袋》。是的，它在Stitcher Premium上。
And this is where we are going to answer even more of your questions about the show, particularly the things that you think we missed the first time around. We're going to miss a bunch of things. Oh, we already have. We already have. Believe me. And we have heard from you. But also, we get a lot of questions.
在这里，我们将回答更多关于这个节目的问题，特别是你们认为我们在第一遍时漏掉的东西。我们会漏掉很多东西。哦，我们已经漏掉了。我们已经漏掉了。相信我。我们已经听取了你们的意见。而且，我们也收到了很多问题。
We could do almost a whole episode with just fan questions. And so we are. And so we are. We're going to do it a little bit at a time and we're going to answer your questions. Look for us over on Stitcher Premium, Office Ladies Candy Bag. It's named after the candy bag on the office, which is the place where we put all of our extra stuff. Our extra stuff, you guys.
我们几乎可以用粉丝的问题做整整一集节目。所以我们正在这么做。我们正在这么做。我们会一点一点地来回答你们的问题。在Stitcher Premium上寻找我们，《办公室女士糖果袋》。它的名字取自办公室里的糖果袋，那是我们存放所有额外内容的地方。我们的额外内容，伙计们。
And you get a discount if you use code Office Ladies for the first month. We're going to get to your questions, all the things we missed on the pilot and diversity day. Guys, I heard you. I missed the shredder thing. Oh my God. We will discuss. Did Jenna hear you or did she hear you?
如果你在第一个月使用代码Office Ladies，还可以享受折扣。我们会回答你们的问题，关于试播集和多元化日所有我们漏掉的事情。伙计们，我听到你们的声音了。我漏掉了碎纸机的事情。天哪。我们会讨论的。珍娜听到你们了吗，还是她听到你们了？
I heard you. That was it. That's the Dundee. That is the Dundies. Please email us at officeladiesatearwolf.com if you feel like we missed anything, we will get to it. Yes. Sorry if we did, but we love this episode and we're always happy to talk more about
我听到了。就是这样。这就是邓迪奖。这就是邓迪奖。如果你觉得我们漏掉了什么，请发邮件至officeladiesatearwolf.com，我们会处理的。是的。如果我们漏掉了，请原谅，但我们很喜欢这一集，而且我们总是很高兴谈论更多关于
it. And next week, we will be talking about sexual harassment. The episode sexual harassment. Correct. We will be talking about the episode sexual harassment. All right. You guys, see you then. Thanks for tuning in.
它的内容。下周，我们将讨论性骚扰。性骚扰那一集。没错。我们将讨论性骚扰那一集。好了。伙计们，到时候见。谢谢收听。
Thank you. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey. Our producer is Cody Fisher. Our sound engineer is Sam Heifer. And our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. Remember you can listen to ad-free versions of Office Ladies on Stitcher Premium. For a free month of Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
谢谢。谢谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。我们的制作人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的音响工程师是萨姆·海弗。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。记住，你可以在Stitcher Premium上收听《办公室女士》的无广告版本。要获得一个月的免费Stitcher Premium，请使用代码Office。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。